hello everybody welcome back to the i'm
not gm speed chess championship grand
master
robert s alongside me today once again
grandmaster mont hamilton
amman we have a great matchup in store
today don't we
yeah what's up robert what's up
everybody we are
about to get into an exciting match up
which is going to be uh international
master levi rosman against
national master james canty and i'm very
excited to call this one with you robert
me too these are two very popular chess
content creators
and before we get into the specifics of
those two let's talk about the format
overall just to remind everybody what
they are
tuning in for because it's a knockout
tournament
there will be 75 minutes of the longest
time patrol
a five minute plus one second increment
blitz 45 minutes of three minute plus
one second blitz and then finally the 25
minutes of
bullet chess and there are those breaks
in between we saw those
last time they can come in handy for
players to stop the bleeding if they've
lost a couple of
games in a row and also just to refresh
and for our viewers to take a step back
and enjoy the chess
but i'm on the prize fund as we see here
still
the same as it in the round of 16. we
have a 500
per match pretty good prize money for a
couple hours of blitz right
yeah not bad at all i think it's it's
nice that basically if you
are participating in the i am not a gm
tournament
you are getting paid something no matter
what and it only gets better from there
for sure and it's by win percentage uh
half of that prize fund so there's
always something to play for even to the
very last game no matter
what the score of the match is and
speaking of score matches let's take a
peek at the overall bracket last time we
were
together amman we saw lawrence trent
take down danny wrench
and this time we have the lower left
side of the bracket
the four seed levee rosman that's gotham
chess taking on james cannon the third
so it's an
international master vs national master
matchup down there in the bottom left so
why don't we start making predictions
what are your thoughts on about this
match that we're going to see today
well a few things have to be said going
into this match robert um
we can't forget that levy is definitely
the favorite going in
but he might not be as much of a
favorite as
as people think so james canty i think
one of the most uh
kind of remarkable things that i didn't
really know about him is that
uh we checked his his bullet rating and
i think he was actually higher than
some of the international masters we
commentated the last match up
lawrence trent danny wrench like this
guy's no joke and bullet he's actually
rocking like a
a mid 2600 bullet rating which is
extremely impressive so
uh james candy in the bullet section you
know beware beware
i'm with you because i think that's the
time control where
you often see the stronger player or the
player who's just much more accustomed
to playing online
they thrive in that quickest time patrol
but james candy iii
no slouch in the bullet portion and he's
ready to take on levy and levy was in a
slump we saw him tweet about that
saying he's finally out of it he took
down a grand master in a bunch of blitz
games
he's feeling much more confident and
he's breathing a sigh of relief that
that bad form hopefully for him is a
thing of the past but
aman i mean it is interesting because
levy has to be the favorite right he is
much higher rated he has the higher
title
but how do you kind of put that aside
when you're playing a head-to-head match
for so long because let's say james wins
the first game
now sudden are you really still the
favorite the answer is yes objectively
right
statistically speaking but how do you
kind of quell the nerves
in a match like this well yeah you just
always refer to the betting lines robert
always tell yourself in the head i'm
still a betting favorite
if you're if you're levy that that'll
that'll calm you right down
um but no the the thing is if you get
behind in a match like this you really
have
to have those cool nerves i think that
um being a streamer
uh sometimes it means you have more
turbulent emotions but i think it can
also help keep those emotions in check
uh because you're streaming for a large
audience some things might not
go your way while you're streaming you
have to maintain that entertainer phase
and and keep it cool so i think he
probably has a lot of experience in that
department so
could actually help him uh in this match
today absolutely and well it's a natural
segue when you're talking about
streaming for
hours and trying to keep your composure
arena king season six
did start on monday we have another
event this coming friday here
and it's always a lot of fun couple
hours of blitz chess there's going to be
some
chess 960 in addition to classical well
standard chess dishes that's not
classical time patrol but arena king
season six is
already underway and among we have a
pretty huge announcement that was made
just the other day and that is that pog
champs
three is happening as we see two of the
biggest streamers on the planet xqc and
ludwig return
for season three of pogchamps and of
course we have an online chess first
as code miko joins the field as the
first in vtuber tournament hosted by
chess.com so ahmand you see that graphic
there
you're pretty pumped for another pog
champs i i like watching
uh these kind of events where you've got
the you know the lower rated uh players
getting into chess
being coached by the you know the the
studs of our chess community here and
and bringing a lot more eyes to the
chess directory robert so
good thing all around i'm glad chats.com
brought it back absolutely it's going to
be
another fun edition of pogchamps some
new faces
we'll join the fold and it should be
another great event highly entertaining
and i just love the graphics on this by
the way and i know that uh
yeah there's a lot of hard work put into
it but i just find it really cool with
kind of the backdrop behind the players
and
of course the ludwig salute yep shout
out to the graphic team
oh well we do have just a couple minutes
now before the
match gets started if you're on the go
do download the app so you can watch all
the games they
happen before your eyes you will not
want to miss this one as well
two of our favorite content creators
james candy the third that's gm canty
and i think we need to have a word with
him on because that
is explicitly not allowed in this
tournament
gm canty there are no gm's in this field
so
to revoke his invitation uh listen
i i didn't realize that the gm's could
sneak in like that and
with the prizes that are at stake here
robert i might have to go for a username
change one of these days
so you're gonna go on by amman i i am
amman i'm trying to figure out how i can
do this just change the a in your first
name to
iman right yeah i might just add it on
to k and v
b i n k so we'll show up as
i am gm k mvp i think that works well
uh well we see the the players seated
levy as usual in a hoodie and i love
james's hat like the fact that it just
says that's not a move
and nobody has that kind of quick banter
talk like james canty when it comes to
talking about chess it's just so fun
yeah you've never heard that expression
it's it's very much a chess-ism
uh where you know you're just playing a
quick blitz game
some guy does something that looks
pretty sketchy you're pretty sure it's
not a good move and immediately you look
at it you're like
that's not a move you're talking about
buddies so
yeah very much uh very much a gm candy
hat right there so
i agree i like the i like the swag for
sure
and well i see many people in the chat
talking about
uh levy and you know who they're putting
their money on and
well let's talk about how big of a favor
we think that levy is in this match
because
he is the higher the rate of two by
quite a margin in bullet we talked about
how
canty is a strong bullet player but
levy's bullet rating is something in the
2800s so that's
quite a force yeah yeah it's it's a lot
higher than
um than candy's rating in most
categories but
i think in bullet the the difference in
the rating
is probably a bit less significant it's
really hard to judge
but um i think that uh canty definitely
has
his chances when you're 2600 plus in in
bullet you can take down 28 hundreds
like
that's not out of your ballpark so
definitely look for the bullet section
in this match to be quite important and
if the match is anywhere around
even or maybe a few games lead in either
direction going into the bullet
then i think that could be a deciding
factor but levy's going to look to get
out to just a clean
good start we already talked about hey
what happens if
maybe he doesn't have the best start
how's he going to recover i think the
simplest
answer is you know just don't lose right
just get off to a good start you don't
have to worry about that so
he's probably looking to get out of the
gate with a comfortable lead and
and never look back yeah for sure and
levy has some huge victories under his
belt in
title tuesday's past i remember he beat
peter svidler at some point so
it's clear that he can punch up and it
is difficult i would say psychologically
when you
feel that pressure that burden of being
the stronger player the higher rate of
player
because then you start putting pressure
on yourself to win and you can't
be like that in the game of chess you
need to be as objective as possible
because if you start thinking in results
results-oriented terms you're not really
putting out your best
game so i think that levy just needs to
go in this with
a very clear slate just say i'm playing
a strong player
let's do this and if he does put out his
best chest
he should be the favorite for sure yeah
and and let's not understate
like being the favorite going into a
match that means james can't i mean he's
got nothing to lose
no one is sitting there you know
expecting him to
uh to come in and crush levy that's not
the expectation so he's got nothing to
lose
he's coming in here with with a head of
steam and for myself
robert i don't really like being a heavy
favorite when i come into a match i
don't know it kind of psyches me out i'd
i'd rather be on like
equal playing field or even be the
underdog um so
so levi's gotta gotta deal with that uh
however
however he does yeah absolutely
especially as
you know these players know so many
people are watching they're used to it
as you pointed out in mon because they
are big streamers at this point
especially levy
gotham chess channels are just soaring
these days but then
with all the eyeballs comes expectation
comes pressure and that could play a
part but he does look pretty chill right
now
he's just waiting for the games to begin
and while candy as always
he's just hanging in there he's just
vibing
speaking of games beginning you you call
it robert and
off we go off we and we don't have a
london system so for a second i thought
we'd get a london from levy with an
early bishop f4 but instead we're
getting a king's indian so fighting
chess
is definitely on the table here in game
one
yeah um the the london is something that
basically levy a guy like levy or anyone
that competes in these type of events
it's always going to have
in reserve it's like hey if things start
going poorly i always have this you know
trusty opening that i can rely on
uh for a decent position but let me try
some more classical approaches here
we see just a normal d4 game into a
king's indian and already this
uh somewhat crazy looking g4 move robert
can you
explain this one to people who might
think that levy's gone mad and starting
to go king hunting early on well this
move g4
is preemptive it's trying to anticipate
black moving the knight away and playing
pawn to f5
but it also has the benefit of playing
h4 g5 h5 and storming your pawns
down the board and creating attack of
your own but i think the major issue
as a standard uh is when there's a king
in the center
that king often is more vulnerable than
a king sitting on g8 with a fiance
structure around it so
i mean amman this bishop f3 move also
caught me a bit off guard
i thought they usually put the pawn on
f3 but it seems like
levy's going marching forward here for
the attack
yeah it also seems like he kind of has a
plan or setup in mind that he's trying
to go for it i guess i wouldn't be
surprised now that the bishop's on f3
if this knight maybe found itself going
to g3 the nice thing about not playing
the pawn to f3
and first moving the pawn is that black
doesn't ever have access to the h5
square so sometimes when the pawn is on
f3 you plant that knight on h5
and sometimes you even come into f4
white never wants to give away the
bishop for the knight like that
and the way that he's done it there's no
knight h5 so that knight is going to
have to probably go backwards robert and
then we might
see your plan h4h5 opening up that h5
and the fact that james is thinking i
was about to say i think he might be
considering knight h5
even though it's a pawn sacrifice if the
queen ends up on h5 the d3 square
becomes available to that knight on c5
so you can't just go ahead and grab a
pawn even if it looks free
you have to think of the consequences a
few moves down the line so
levy first takes the knight on c5 now i
think he takes the other knight
so we get a situation amman two bishops
but the two knights have an extra pawn
and those bishops don't exactly have
open space i feel like
white has to objectively be better but
it could be difficult if
suddenly james opens the position up
with the timely b5 or something like
that yeah i'm i'm waiting for
f5 to appear on the board in this
position basically if
you know if the g pawn takes maybe the
queen takes and all of a sudden we have
that immediate activity
and there's there's that f5 on the board
it is that
typical looking move that you want to
play when you have those bishops bishops
thrive in open positions
and as robert mentioned moves like b5
moves like f5 they challenge the pawn
chain
and even at the cost of potentially
another pawn
just opening the position up i mean
levy's king is
uh you know it doesn't have a lot of
defenders uh
very close to him so this this could
actually work out for
for james but it's gonna be an exciting
game either way with two bishops against
two knights
yeah it seems like white should have the
quicker attack because you stole a pawn
that was in front of black's king
but if you cast a queen side for white
then queen a5 happens and
even if there's nothing concretely there
it just feels like a position where very
quickly
black is picking up steam and often
that's what you need in a blitz game
just to concern your opponent even if
there's nothing specifically
that is so dangerous it's like that
threat is stronger than the execution
the very popular chess quote
so i think that holds true in a position
like this
definitely and he's going for f3 so so
just looking to maintain the center
yeah and i saw the eval bar take a huge
dip there so there's something about
that move that
is there's a drawback to it and i'm
wondering if just opening up the file to
begin with
makes sense because uh that makes your
rook on a fade more powerful
perhaps you can play on both sides of
the board with that later coming to f2
for instance it just
feels like a situation where white needs
to tread carefully
yeah in terms of concrete lines i was
even looking at takes takes rook f4
intending bishop g4 and it kind of looks
like maybe just for a brief moment you
could stop levy's king from
getting to the queen side which is
exactly i was going to say where he's
going to go right now
yeah so levy quickly runs that king over
and now queen b4 comes to mind can i
just pick off your c4 pawn with my queen
because
and that's what's played white doesn't
have many defenders over
by his king so is black going to have
the attack here is white somehow going
to press
forward i think they both are going to
have the attack here
it's just one of these annoying
positions where if white ever plays g6
you play h6 and it's like wait
i should have something of a pawn on g6
your king is there
but that pawn on h6 just closes down the
entire king side
absolutely yeah g6 h6 and there's no g
file for you to play on um it's not that
easy
to break through whereas for black i
don't know what the evaluation
of this might be but at least you kind
of know what you're up to you know
you've got b5 conan you're already
hitting this pawn
knight e2 by levy this is sort of what i
expected he needs to finish his
development
and we might see ideas like king b1 is a
common move knight g3
trying to get into g5 but b5 b4 by black
is coming sooner than you'd like to see
it what about rook hg-1 rook g3 rook hd
do i have time for that probably not
but i just don't see how i attack and
it's a position where it feels like
white
has to go and attack the black king but
that feels very slow and black can
always move the f pawn because if that
pawn goes you no longer have access to
the h3 square as the bishop
cuts down the diagonal yeah you in fact
you could even be worse you could wait
for the guy to go rook g3 and then play
f4 and just
cover the square from there yeah i
really feel like
from a psychological point of view it's
easier to play as black here i mean even
a move like pawn takes c6
has the drawback of after b takes c6 the
b file opens up so you ruin black's pawn
structure
but that opening of another file where
your king is that seems very
dangerous yep um i think there's
probably a way to play where you maybe
just take on c6
and just double the rooks on the d file
and and sort of just just play chess
from there
um you know you're covering b2 that way
the knight's always watching a2
and don't see a way that this bishop on
g7 can enter the game like if that pawn
on e5
almost disappears like if it wasn't
there or if it ever moves in this game
white has to be very very careful
a queen h4 plate and that eval bar takes
another hit
i think the previous move white was
apparently doing well according to the
engine but
you and i robert we're looking at this
position and kind of reminding people
that hey
it might look like an advantage for
white but um you know black's attacking
ideas seem to be easier to execute
uh than whites and i think that's what
maybe levy's is kind of realizing here
is the time advantage is also quite
significant
yeah even in this position uh it's
actually difficult for black as well
because
i'm looking at this position i'm
thinking pawn takes e4 i'm thinking of
pawn takes d5
i think do i leave the tension as it
currently exists i think i would take on
d5
because i have the bishops i want to
open up the board but i can see the
drawback of that he does take on d5
because if
the uh d file can be under white's
control
that could be a problem for black but i
starting to like james position more and
more
yeah and not that this was ever his
intention but with the queen on
on h4 he can't take with the e pawn
there was a pin there
and after queen a6 i think his intention
was to meet
this move with b3 and knight takes d5
but maybe he's noticing after queen a6
like
taking that pawn is is actually not so
not so good he gets a 97
check maybe king h8 g6 but that move h6
kind of always saves the day yeah the
knight and e2 is also hanging out maybe
taking a2 is better
honestly because uh you're closer to the
white king but then e2 is hanging in
that variation if the knight moves from
c3
so maybe there's some kind of knight d5
97 knight g6 check
like just a back and forth of a
repetition if the king goes to h8 but
maybe that king goes to f7 and now
i think so and look at that bar takes it
takes dip again h6 has to be the
response right
yeah i think he's he's trying to be
tricky because sometimes
when you're intending these long
calculations and then you see like
some line where oh my pawn would be
better if it was on g6
you start with that move and then your
opponent might not expect that you're
just sort of slowly
subtly inserting that into a long
calculation
right and yeah that's a good point
because for example h takes g6 now
oh it does it i was thinking knight
takes d5 becomes more powerful in many
of these variations
because you no longer have access to the
h file so 97 could be devastating
but the problem with knight d5 is we're
talking about the a2 pawn the knight on
e2 both hanging
rook g1 doesn't actually threaten
anything just yet the pawn on g6 is
defended by the queen
but of course we see the potential here
of a knight coming to d5 or
taking on g6 the 97 check there are many
ideas for levy
as we like to say in chess it threatens
to threaten
precisely that one of the scariest
things um and if d4
which as as you pointed out earlier kind
of wins quote unquote wins that night
i think that's what levy's actually
intending to give up that night play
rook takes g6 get that other rook over
suddenly he's the one on the offensive
so if canty gets too greedy here he
could flip
completely in levy's favor so don't be
too worried if you're a levy fan
looking at that eval minus 2.5 although
this game's over
not at all this game could just go topsy
turvy when everyone's attacking
and we're getting a bullet scramble
because the players are now
down under 30 seconds per side the g6
pawn feels weak black is up two pawns
i would consider playing he plays d4 i
was considering pawn takes e4 f takes
and just trying to open the position up
for that rook on a fade
but he goes this way i i don't like this
i feel like levy's levy's getting
what he wants that's the point of rook
there with time ticking down this
is not it no no no this can't be i mean
you see the evaluation bar go up
very high in white sphere rook takes g6
threatens rook g1 or even rook takes g7
sacrifices for a quick mate
this has to be winning for white oh okay
so he wants to slide the
rook over first which i just don't think
it can be
the right way to go but i i see what
he's trying to do
and he takes on g6 how do you do this
queen f1 check is just met by king b2
for example the king runs away so
how do you actually get out of this but
the thing is what's the
actual threat because rick takes g7
there's no rook g2 to follow up
oh that's a good point so like that's
why the rook was better on d1 which is
why
canty's actually hooped himself by
checking that was the wrong thing to do
2.6 seconds levy's gonna get that win
but i think rook d2 was actually the
mistake
and then canty said hang on let me fix
that rook for you and didn't realize he
was doing that
and levy's attack pays off in game one
robert won nothing for levy yeah we
should pull up an analysis board real
quick because that's a very instructive
moment that you're pointing out that the
rook needed access to the g file to make
it work so
uh come on if you pull up the last game
yeah and just yeah
that was just so instructive there and
that's why rook d2 was actually a bad
move and rough takes g6 was so strong
yeah if you start with rook takes g6
then
basically the threat is you're gonna
take this you're gonna bring the rook
over give another check
so if i just make a move for black we'll
show what white is threatening
something like this check and
leading to checkmate on e7 so you need
to have the g file
accessible and in the game what we
actually saw was
rook d2 and then rook g6 and now that's
not a threat because
g2 is covered yep so it's it's a slower
approach and that's all the time black
would have needed to
try to save the king it was very
difficult you're under duress on the
clock on the board
james actually didn't even seem like he
realized he was in time trouble and that
can be
something that players fall victim to in
these five-minute portions because
they're not
used to having so much time and they
think that they have all the time in the
world and next thing you know your
clock has fallen absolutely and
and both of these players in that time
scramble
didn't look the most comfortable but
i'll give credit to levy there because
he was like 20 seconds to about a minute
minute and a half or something and he
was really down on time
and he clawed all the way back in order
to get that win
on time so very impressive speed and
and accuracy at the same time uh by levy
for sure and has levy been taking
lessons from yasser sarwan because he's
playing the black side of a karo khan
and it was the panel variation which is
why white is currently up upon but
they're doubled
on the d file there and a typical idea
for black is to go
knight c7 try to win the pawn back but
you have to consider things like hey
does bishop c4
just just played does that save the pawn
i mean you're talking about lessons from
yasser i was like wait a minute he's
down upon yes he would never touch this
position
you know i've actually played yasser
from the white side of this position so
you know he doesn't mind sacrificing a
pawn if it gives him all this quick play
and it's in his beloved karakan where
they're all pawns no hope
yep that makes a lot of sense and like
queen takes a2
is the move that's sort of being
indicated uh yeah and queen a2 is played
keeping a watch on that pawn i wouldn't
be surprised if like
b5 was maybe a move here i'm not too
familiar with the theory
in this position robert but tons of
pressure here
uh and b5 played yeah and i think the
problem here is the knight takes b5
actually drops a piece for white because
there's queen a5
check at the end of the line so b5 is
tactically sound
yep and i guess you could
take on b5 with the bishop but
uh we basically looking at that position
after like bishop a6
white is not going to have any hopes to
castle and you know the price of a pawn
is pretty much not worth it definitely
not and
this is what happens sometimes when you
sort of you win a pawn you try to
protect it
and you're a little bit too focused on
the material and
it makes sense because in many of these
keracon lines from the white side and
the pan off you do
try to protect that pawn but here you're
seeing uh how
james had to allow levy's pawns forward
but the downside of these pawn pushes
right of mine is that his pawn md5 could
become
a weakness as the game continues yeah uh
out of the opening i think levy's got to
be
super happy with how it's gone but um
i'll just give credit to canty although
he may have
ran into someone else's prep he might
not have the best opening he's kept the
time even in fact he's ahead on the
clock
and sometimes when you get in these bad
opening positions at least i can speak
for myself here
robert i overthink them you start to to
worry that your opponent has just got
the whole game prepped
and you get low on time plus the bad
position so
whenever you're in a top position play
quick and at least give yourself a
chance on the clock
yeah low on time is something i'm very
accustomed to so
i feel that you're right that oftentimes
in blitz the best thing you can do
is play decent or good moves quickly
rather than trying to find the perfect
move
every single time and look at james he's
built up a large lead on the clock still
plenty of time of course for levy
his knight on d5 looks very strong but
upon c3
is a target but that's what i was saying
you'd rather for black have your pawns
on
a7 and b6 in this position instead of on
b5
where it's very vulnerable and if b5 is
captured then a4 is a target next
and i think black has sort of lost a bit
of uh the
the pull in the last couple moves like
after pawn takes here i would be a
little bit more attracted to maybe the
move bishop e6
and leaving that knight on c7 guarding
the pawn i feel like after knight d5
bishop d2
uh you pointed out earlier that that
pawn might be a liability and i'm just
wondering you know like
very very quickly the pieces can all
shift over to the b
file you've got the easy e-file access
here
and i'm not so sure how easy it is to
defend that pawn like bishop a6 and
bishop d7
both don't look like moves that either
are playable or that you want to play
totally with you and if especially in
view bishop d7 i guess it's not possible
because the knight d5 is hanging right
now but
that's makes matters even worse so maybe
bishop e6
tactically protecting b5 because of some
discoveries but then you're inviting the
queen over to b2 where you put another
attacker on b5 right it feels like an
awkward position
yeah i think i think the queen is going
to slide to b2 and then we might see
rook b8
something like that but i don't think
you can complain too much if you're
candy here something like rookie one
maybe knight to g5 or trying to get the
knight to e5 eventually
um there is this weak c pawn to target
but
it almost feels like levy doesn't quite
have time to to fully exert all the
pressure
on the c file because he's got his own
pawn to worry about absolutely
and in addition to going after
a backwards pawn which the pawn see
there is you might want to blockade it
by putting a piece in c4 but you just
don't have time to get your knight to b6
and it's
what
[Laughter]
well seems a little unnecessary i guess
it's the best word
um that i can use to describe it c4
right
because of knight b6 then d5 yeah
absolutely knight there
d5 um seems like you're handling
handling things he's gone for it there's
the rogues lose
this bishop is is loose there's a lot of
things going on here
but what you said earlier ahmad look at
the clock situation
james even if this maybe a dubious or
potentially a sacrifice of a backfire
he's moving very quickly and that's
putting a lot of pressure on levy
on the clock and definitely the the eval
bar was sort of in levy's favor there
because of bishop takes a1 the computer
is always going to
just you know grab that material robert
and take it right to the bank and say
yeah no worries we win these
but a human is going to look at that and
be like wait a minute like i can't give
away my dark square bishop like that
white plays queen takes a1 bishop h6
he already gets the piece back or he
looks back it looks like a grunfeld type
of position right where you give up the
rook on a1 and then go checkmate the
king
uh on the king side because that
fianchetto bishop is so important
to a defense on the king side right when
you fianchetto the h6 square
and the dark squares become vulnerable
if that bishop disappears so i think you
can just go ahead and take the pawn on
b5 if you
were willing to give up your rook on a1
once i think you should be willing to
give it up now
yep and and i think james has got the
right strategy
um to to have a chance in this match
robert because what
what he's doing is he's basically
playing fast enough that he's been up on
time
every game and he's saying look we all
know how impressive levy can be in time
scrambles
so just you're gonna have to show me
every time like you're gonna have to
consistently perform
um the the way that he did in game one
and
it's not gonna happen every game there's
going to be a few games where levy's
going to maybe make some blunders in
time pressure and james has got to
capitalize when that moment happens
absolutely but right now i see the eval
bar dip a bit and i can understand why
because
in this position black can take on c4
take on f3
and at the end of it all white is gonna
play g2
takes f3 and the king side pawn
structure is shattered and that's
not what james wanted here so it's
interesting he spent a minute and five
seconds
and then said i'm gonna shy away from
the exchange sacrifice i need to keep my
material so
it feels like he had the right plan and
then he went away from it because
something spooked him
and i i'm not that much of a hater uh on
this position like let's say everything
takes
take here you take with a g pawn your
bishop goes to b4
guards your weak pawn hits e7 you got
your rook exactly where it needs to be
on d1
and you sort of play king g2 queen e4
rookie one
i can really get behind this position
for for white actually and he started
with bishop b4 interesting
oh i like that move because now you're
at least keeping it tactical
and the pawn on d5 should not be
captured i think that would be
it has to be bad right some kind of just
queen 64 even those pins
the bishop one g4 is under attack in
addition to knight on d5 being under
attack so
levy has a lot to calculate he's now
down to 20 seconds and he plays
c3 that's a brave move yeah in the face
of
as you mentioned a lot of tactics
there's h3 i was going to say which i
think he might
whip out here if takes takes he wants to
play d6 and suddenly it's
it's the rook on a8 that's actually
hanging into the white's bishop
and of course if you get the bishop pair
and then the open e file you put a work
on e1
and well that opponent's c3 it is a pass
pawn but it's easy to blockade for the
moment you can just put your queen on c2
and stop that pawn's progress but not a
move you want to play d6 and five
seconds for levy
yeah takes takes queen c7 i think has to
be the
the way to go but then there's rook c6
and you're looking at all right
c6 the bishop on f3 yeah well
t take that for sure you got to just
grab that with the rook
what's he wearing he's thinking of
bishop case
okay queen c7 rook c6 has to be good yep
and this pawn on c3 is going to be
strong but that is material
it is but that dark square bishop will
help your light square bishop will help
blockade the pawn so
he wait take one take on g7 g7 yeah
you go up a piece have you blundered
yeah
and the two bishops should win this game
and i was mentioning that's the strategy
for canty you gotta try to use the the
pressure of the clock and with 1.8
seconds
this is looking tough you only get one
extra second per move not two
yeah and you saw levy's face when he
allowed bishop takes g7 he's just like
you know and that's what happens when
you're in time trouble more than
anything of course
james played a very nice tactical game
but levy didn't have
the time he needed to work through this
rook takes c3 get rid of that pass pawn
you're before peace
i think we'll throw in the towel oh yeah
this is looking really tough the bishop
controls this um like basically you
could put a black
bishop somewhere on the board and white
would probably still be better
yeah we dig d7 that's another free piece
and interesting that he's playing on do
you think he's just trying to waste more
time as we
head you know um i don't i don't think
he's wasting time i think maybe he's
just feeling out like
how confident is james and putting away
these positions like how good is he
maybe when his time gets a little low
how good is he at converting
these games and i think what we saw
there was he's pretty confident
at converting yeah especially up a piece
james is way too strong not to be able
to win that position
but levy goes for his a3 against the
sicilian
and of course levy puts out a ton of
content on various openings
this has been an opening that he has
used before
but at the highest levels you don't see
it very often because you're playing on
the wing
whereas in the opening you often want to
play in the center so
b4 at some moment will be a thematic
pawn sacrifice
i'm it's just interesting to me amanda
maybe you could speak to this better
like why is he playing a kind of offbeat
opening and then spending time after it
yeah it's it's uh i guess it's something
i
somehow relate to basically sometimes
when you play an offbeat opening
you have a few variations that someone
might play or maybe that you're
expecting them to play it's quite
possible that
even though he's playing an offbeat
opening he could have checked what uh
canty plays
and he's trying to play against it and
maybe james just played something new
something different or maybe he played
one of those testing lines against the
opening
the problem with offbeat lines robert is
they usually have either a refutation or
at least a really good reply
so sometimes you play it hoping that the
your opponent
does not play the absolute best thing
and when they do you're kind of like ah
damn it you know my my tricks are aren't
working here
wow and a humongous raid to uh
this broadcast here thank you so much uh
there
wow hicaro raid and of course
gotham chess levy rosman he is often
found on hikaru's channel
so thank you for that huge raid and well
for all of you i'm sure many of you are
rooting on levy rosman he is in a tough
match right now it's one to one
james canty scores a victory in game two
to even the score
and in game three what amon and i have
been talking about is that
hey it's an offbeat opening levy spent
some time now it's james's turn because
he's an unfamiliar
territory himself and i would play a6
just to kick that's not a b5 because
when someone plays something like this
against me
i'm concerned that there's some tactic
that i'm going to overlook so let me
just kick tonight and james does just
that
yeah and welcome to all the raiders i
think levy more than anyone is going to
be happy you guys are here because he
just had a tough loss in this match
so he's gonna need some energy and
support to get back in this thing
for sure and you were saying that hey
you want to get out to a good start and
not have to rely
on your bullet skills that is what levy
did in the first game
he won he was feeling confident after
that now
after game two you lose the momentum may
swing a little bit the other way
and what is happening here in game three
the bishop pair once again
for james canty but those bishops
especially that light square bishop
right now doesn't have anywhere nice to
go
yeah i i actually really like um
levy's opening might not look like much
black has the two bishops you've
actually seen that story in this match
before
but levy's bishop is going to get out to
f4 g5 he's going to go
you know queen something like queen d2
and whether he castles uh long or short
i think he should probably castle
queenside
the rooks are just going to come to the
center of the board and you don't see
many positions in chess where the two
central pawns don't move
and you you sort of have a good position
with the black pieces like you generally
do have to take the center at some point
and yeah just playing the center here
with a move like d6 that doesn't feel
right because then
he plays d5 but we can see all these
exchanges take place
where you take ampisant right the pawn
move two squares and for now you can
take it as if it moved one so you take
on d6
you can trade queens on d6 and that pawn
on d6 that remains will be a backwards
pawn which
i wouldn't be so thrilled about but
james says i've assessed my
odds here i have to go with this
otherwise i'm going to
be dominating the center there we go
and that was one of the that was one of
the most interesting first time
experience for me we had a hikara raid
and then he carved started up his stream
again maybe what we're doing are we like
viewer farming right now so
fifteen thousand viewer raid hikaru
streams we're gonna get fifteen thousand
more viewers that will rate him again
and we'll just keep doing that robert i
like the cycle let's go
hey you know that that works for us and
of course for
many of you who are tuning in as fans of
both of these
content creators and we welcome all of
you so
we see that james is king now sitting on
e7 not
very well placed with a rook coming to
e1 with check for example but he puts
the bishop on e6
he can move his king out of the way and
it still feels to me that despite the
double c pawns that white should be
slightly better
i'm just not quite sure how to prove it
yeah and i think the nice thing to look
forward to
um in any type of end game here is that
uh it might not look like much but just
the presence of those two pawns
indicates that black spawns are
generally going to be stuck on
light squares and this light square
bishop isn't going to have any targets
to attack if white just plays g3 it's
like
imagine an end game this bishop is just
dancing around these bonds but can't
attack them
so i i feel like levy is is going to be
happy with
uh getting an endgame finally a less
tactical game
you know he can sort of calm down a bit
he's got the white pieces he's not down
uh that much on time right now so i
think he's gonna be happy just to have a
chill game
robert to sort of break the momentum i'm
with you but there is something
frustrating about
knowing that you have a slightly better
position but not really on
not necessarily understanding but not
finding a way to capitalize on it and i
think that's what's happening right here
at least from my point of view white is
better you have a knight against a
bishop
why does the knight become better than a
bishop in a position like this then
knight can just sit on a dark square the
bishop can do nothing to attack it
but where is the follow-up i think king
d7 makes sense here that way you
avoid the pin that the pawn c4 then
really becomes under attack
and if you have your d6 pawn under
attack you just put your king on c7 so
you just
run your king to safety and i don't know
i'm not really seeing
where white is going to make progress
from
no that's i think in a uh
in a classical game you know that this
wouldn't be anything to to write home
but in a blitz game sometimes these
advantages are
often a little bit more pronounced um
than than you might think so
um we'll see how the game develops but i
certainly agree there it shouldn't
really be anything here for
for levy but you know he's he's got a
slightly better position
and it depends really how comfortable he
is grinding down these small advantages
some players as as you know robert are
specialists there that's their kind of
chess
and some players are they just wish the
position had a queen on it and it was
more tactical
yeah there are definitely people with
those preferences
and well b3 played to defend the c4 pawn
now
94 check rook e to d3 come to mind
as a way to hit upon dark square we talk
about the
problem with a bishop it can't protect
pieces on the opposite color and so that
d6 pawn
cemented backwards that's going to be a
problem for james i didn't really like
to move king f6 i feel like he's moving
his king away
from a lot of the action on the queen
side yeah i think he was maybe a little
bit scared to play king d7 just because
it looks funny like walking into the
rooks so he wants to get out of the way
but i think king d7 was actually the
better move and
b5 has been played which if that gets
taken
a takes b5 we're going to have an
imbalance where in an end game there is
going to be an outside a pawn might not
look like much right now but
that could be the the major difference
in the position
for sure because that pawn you can use
as a decoy distract black's pieces
that have to deal with that running
passer and then white can operate on the
other side of the board so rook f3
check is played and well i see two
options one is bishop f5 just blocking
the check with your bishop you can't
play g4 because that pawn on h5
that's the good news about that pawn
being on h5 and honestly
king g7 he played looks fine as well
rook to d3
you probably just played d5 and protect
your palm yeah
the weird thing about that position is i
was actually feeling pretty confident
that bishop f5 was one of the better
moves
um there was no g4 as you mentioned and
bishop f5 also opens up
rook e2 next hitting c2 and just getting
on the second rank and if white goes
something like
rook d2 it just feels like white is
somehow assuming the
uh slightly more passive role at the
moment i'm with you
and gotta shout out tree poker for
gifting
tons of subs we really appreciate that
uh thank you for
your support of chess and the channel so
appreciate it and he's not even done
he's gifting more subs as we're thanking
him
thanks a lot tree poker very kind oh
that's awesome and look at this we have
uh
an end game with two rooks per side
white no longer has those double pawns
black no longer is suffering with a
questionable bishop against a good
knight
so this feels like a position where it
should be a hold but amount of keeping
your idea in the back of my mind that
outside a pawn
has me preferring white's position in
the long run
okay and i'll take the other side and
and present
not only the maybe one minute time
advantage i think that's going to be a
bit relevant
but also that black's weak pawn can be
defended kind of nicely by king e7
the king's in the center of the board
and you know if if black ever attacks
this a pawn white's king has to go
pretty far
to the queen side and might leave the
center exposed so the nice thing about
using the king
to defend one of your weak pawns is
suddenly it frees up one of the rooks
suddenly rookie 2 rookie 4 or rook 88
are all possible
but i do think that the clock is
something we need to pay attention to
because
unfortunately it was the detriment of
levy in that last game you had a great
game but i mentioned
levy's great under time pressure but
he's not going to be great every single
game
absolutely and g3 played so levi has 18
seconds left
he could consider b4 actually now that i
look at the position just to try to get
to the b5 pawn
where the rook on d5 looks very
promising and james has no fear he's
just
pushing his pawns forward he can even
consider f4 at some point as black
to give away a pawn than to ruin the
pawn structure that remains for white
absolutely and levy's going for this
position where he says look
my rook defends my pawn and my pawn
defends my pawn my pawn defense my pawn
is nothing
you know that that's left loose uh in
this position and then as we've been
mentioning
a pawn runs to the end of the board in
any type of king and pawn end game
so 14 seconds to 30 seconds time is
evening up here
i think the evaluation is around equal
but i have a feeling someone's gonna win
this game robert
well i don't like what's happening with
levy's clock he's down to seven seconds
and
when you play an end game like this
which may seem just completely docile
it's an even position nothing to worry
about
then you look at your clock you freak
out make a quick move and your position
becomes worse
by the time i think you should consider
b4 that's the move i keep looking at for
white trying to change the pawn
structure and
use that rook on d5 to your advantage
and look at that there we go and there
the rook comes in i think rook e4
intending maybe f4 is the way to go but
this is good as well
and i'm really looking at that outside a
pawn now
yeah so what levy wants to do is he
wants to get his king up put his rook
behind that pawn
and try to push it as far as it'll go
and win the king and pawn end game
canty has to be very careful here in my
opinion oh certainly because this is one
of those positions where it looks
completely even and you lose
because of the outside pawn imagine the
rooks are off the board oh this is bad
this is getting bad rook d2
next already looks a bit sketchy yep
and here king d4 rook d2 check the good
news is the king needs to stay on b4
to protect a5 so it won't be able to
take that's a good move yeah that's a
great move king e4
and now king d3 or kd4 okay c3
you're gonna stack c2 just place okay
this still works king e2 maybe
king d2 but he's gotta make movies last
time oh no
oh my gosh robert i just had this
terrible feeling that someone was gonna
lose this game
it's a draw it's equal evaluation but it
requires so much accuracy
and wow wow that's exactly
what levy needed if you're in the lobby
rosman camp i mean you're definitely
cheering for that result but
just tragic for kante who played a great
game robert and lost it at the very end
on time
and in the words of james candy's hat
that's not a move
you had to make a move and this is on
time
oh my gosh that is so heartbreaking and
we're about to go into
our break the players get to take a
little bit of rest but that
must feel horrible as you head into this
break you're going to try to recover
from it
but it was great defense that whole game
by james canty the third
and then you lose on the clock that is
i'm sorry to say devastating
for team danny it is now as devastating
as that is robert as we head into our
break james has to remember that
he's only down one game and when we come
back there's gonna be the rest of
the five minute portion for sure and for
all you out there who are fans of these
great content creators gotham chess and
jim canty
we will be right back in a few minutes
for more action from the i'm not gm
speeches championship brought to you by
chess.com
and we return getting ready for more
five-minute plus one-second increment
games from this i'm not gm speed just
championship match
between gotham chess and gm canty
amman canty still must be hurting he
must be reeling after losing on time in
that game
how can he recover yeah i robert
i think it's really important for canty
here to
not let the emotions get the better of
him i don't know what type of player he
is
uh in terms of controlling his emotions
and how much a loss might affect him
going into the next game i think that's
kind of a question mark for a lot of us
uh he seems like you know so chill so
vibin when when he's playing
um and before the match so if he has
that same type of energy
i think that's exactly what he needs
right now just put it behind him
you know i think he's already maybe over
performing from what some people thought
going into this match it's two to one
and
he's maybe had a chance to win almost
every game uh in this match so far
roberts
i think he's doing great and he needs to
remind himself of that i think it's an
excellent point because when you come as
the underdog you need to
believe that you can do it and based on
the three games we've seen thus far
he should believe that he can do it he
has been every step of the way
in these games he has you know lost the
first game then just lost this
last game on time but he is clearly a
worthy competitor and somebody who can
challenge
a great player in gotham chess and right
now candy gets the white pieces again
we'll see this pan off maybe james
looked at it during the break that is
the benefit of having a break is you can
improve
on what you did in previous games yeah
and it's recommended
even uh that's that's what a lot of the
players
use and should use that brake force
we'll see if canty has looked at this we
saw
that this was kind of pivotal in a lot
of other matches at least that i've
commentated
in this i'm not a gm tournament so far
it's like you use that break
to actually double check the line check
it with an engine oh if this opening
didn't go well last time
what critical mistake did i make and
let's simply change that
for the upcoming round so both players
are looking to repeat this i understand
why levy's repeating hey
you worked fantastic last time he's
gonna take that position every game
but canty if he's repeating this he
better have something new prepared and
look what we see on the board bishop f3
that is a new move exactly he's
protecting the d5 pawn
with the bishop on a safer square
remember that last game where knight a6
knight c7
and then b5 just made white's pieces
feel
uncomfortable that bishop on f3 you're
not attacking that good luck to you
and so now the knight can come to e2 and
maybe even eventually to f4
to make that pawn on d5 feel extra
nicely defended
yep and bishop f3 i think is the move
that i've seen a little bit more often
so kante basically just changed one
single move but he's basically he's
gonna go with the same setup that's the
nice thing it doesn't change that much
about what he knows about the position
but he is playing a move that the engine
prefers here so
small adjustment and it could make all
the difference here as he once again has
jumped out to that
early lead robert what do you make of
this ante
always seems to be up on the clock yeah
in the early stages that has been the
case
and even actually later in the game but
that's worries me a bit
for the three minute portion if i'm a
gotham chess fan because
then you don't have all this time to
spend in the early
part of the game but here he plays a
move b5 this is thematic
where you give up another pawn that's a
pawn that's not defended so
white can grab it in two different ways
but the point is the quick activity that
black
is able to obtain for the cost of
another pawn is worth it there's a king
on e1
not yet ready to castle yeah that's a
great point and
the funny thing about a move like b5 is
it kind of walks into d6
uncovering the bishop's attack of the
rook but you just sidestep that attack
and say yeah go ahead and take my
opponent e7 i'll be more than happy to
develop with check
yeah it's one of these positions where
it's all about that king being the
center because normally d6 would be a
great move where
you're using one of your doubled
isolated pawns and trading it off for a
healthy pawn e7 but
it opens the e file without a pawn there
that's gonna
backfire a4 i mean levy's just
no respect for his own pawns it feels
like here robert he's just
chucking them left right and center you
know he pro the apon probably saw
levy grab that b-pawn and then suddenly
he was off the board and he sees him
reaching for the a-pawn he's like oh no
it's my turn
you know if i'm benny watts i'm taking
my nice little caracon matcha back
because he says
all pawns no hope levy says no pawns
i'll hope and
look at him go here he wants to go after
the center and i wouldn't be surprised
if
like e6 was possible there saying you
know take my pawn e6 i'm opening the
file up your king
still sits on anyone whatever just chuck
them all
to the wayside and bishop b7 knight back
to c3
by canty and we actually see a similar
position to last game but that bishop on
f3
it just has to be better placed there
for sure it's just
much more stable it can't be attacked
white is going to play knight g1 to e2
so i can see where the play comes from
for levy he can play knight c7 go after
the opponent d5
but white's moves are also pretty easy
to spot knight e2
castle move your queen away when it gets
under attack so i
i don't see the entire compensation for
two sacrifice pawns you will likely
regain one back
but i don't think it's sufficient for
true equality there's some dynamic play
that black has
but i would prefer to have james's
position at this point
yep no and he's he's played it again
he's up more than a minute
here and if you're up more than a minute
and you're up a pawn the worst that's
going to happen
most likely is you lose maybe that pawn
back so
i think i think you should be i think
you should be uh happy with what we see
here
and that's one of the things that i
think boggs players down myself included
where
is that if i've given up material and i
see a way to cut that deficit from two
pawns in one pawn i'm like
wait then what i'm still down a pawn and
you start allowing that to weigh on you
and you need to play dynamically and you
need to play quickly look at james canty
once again up a minute and 40 plus
almost two minutes like i i just want to
speak on maybe the time management
because this is so relatable for me uh
usually when you're a player that is
confident in your bullet skills and we
know levy you know rocking that
2850 bullet rating when you're confident
in your bullet skills and you know
how good of a time scrambler you are how
good at making up deficits you are
sometimes when you see your clock
ticking down 145 you're like
whatever you know when i have five
seconds like you know i'm a god like i
can handle that
but you don't need to put yourself in
that position
usually you want to have those skills
reserved for when you need them and then
you know you can show up and and save a
tough position but you don't want to be
getting
in that in that type of time pressure
every single game it's so easy to let
that happen
when you see this time and you're like
yeah you know it's no problem i'm a good
bullet player
yeah i'm completely with you and i'm
looking at the time spent on queen b6
black's last move levy spent a minute
and 43 seconds on knight g to e2
james only spent 18.6 seconds and this
is the type position
where white is better over the board but
his biggest advantage may be on the
clock
as he is up so much time here and black
doesn't
have clear access to saying i've
made up for the fact that i'm down a
bunch of pawns it's not a clear position
so time is so important absolutely and
and even after the move queen a2 which
might not be the preferred move maybe he
goes queen d3 but
just looking at queen a2 like let's say
you go greedy
that depon's defended on d5 the d-pawn
on d4 is defended
the knight can't get into b4 or c5 and
you're castling next turn it
it just feels like uh like you got to
put the appropriate weight on being up
about two minutes here like that that's
an advantage and that's part of the game
and the pawn a4
that's a loner so even if you go pile up
pressure on the d pawn on
one of those pawns you may drop your
pawn on the a file so
i would just play queen a2 then i would
castle pretty much no matter what black
does and say prove it prove that you
have what it takes to come back from a
two pawn deficit
especially when you are down so much
time yeah probably knight
c7 i'm trying to come up with another
move but knight's d7 looks like it
and levy has played queen b6 rook c8 but
neither of those moves actually
contribute to
getting that d-pawn back so i'm
wondering what his plan is with those
moves is he someone going to use the
pieces like the knight on a6
looks like he can only go to c7 i'm
wondering what his plan is in the next
couple of moves robert
that's frustrating right you want to
play knight c7 queen d6 and you realize
that even if you get those two moves
then bishop f4
can be a response the knight on he2 can
go to f4 itself but it defends that
square so the bishop would be able to
develop with tempo
queen b3 trading off queens when you're
down two pawns
maybe it's all right but i would be very
reluctant to
do something like that yep and uh
one important thing which i think levy's
relying on is that his knight might get
into the action with knight b4
using that pin on the a file knight d3
check knight c2 check
it's all about takes takes and levy
wants to play knight before so keep an
eye on that
james can look to prevent that with like
rook b1 afterwards
or he could just develop his pieces and
say look you know you can have that
knight in you can have that square i'm
still
up two pawns yeah i think he should
trade queens but maybe he doesn't have
to because what is black's threat are
you really just going to take on a2 that
doesn't scare him so he
actually castles that's probably the
better option it doesn't give levy those
tactics that you were just talking about
him on
so with 30 seconds to two minutes prove
it and i think this is a great strategy
by james in this game
you lost game three on time now in game
four you keep saying you prove it
you show me that you can have sufficient
compensation for the material
and queen c2 i mean this has got to be
in uh james favor here the bishop can
just develop
and after the bishop develops i mean the
rook just slides over to c1 i don't see
any issues in the position here for
james i i mean take your pick about
where you want to develop that bishop to
but
rick c1 rookie one rook d1 are coming i
i like what james has got going on here
yeah and all with tempo right so bishop
g5 perhaps just to try to even take on
that
he was bishop e3 that's more solid i
like that as you said rook c1 rook d1
that knight can go to f4 if you attack
d5 again i
can't get behind this position uh i
think that it's just
too much trouble for levy especially
with 12.7 seconds
and i think levy is planning to go queen
f5 if he gets attacked queen back to d7
at least reclaim that d-pawn and then go
from there
but bishop b3 is a nice move because it
watches d4 and as you mentioned it lets
knight f4 happen
watching d5 so everything's covered here
um in kante's position
okay so now knight h5 was the first one
that came to my mind once you push upon
you
sort of relinquish control over the
square that it previously was covering
so knight h5 trades some pieces it also
removes an attacker
of the d5 pawn the g5 pawn itself is
weak because it's bishop on e3 so
i think that's a pretty good move to
make and keep in mind
there's also d6 as a threat hitting f7
long range and the knight in that
position after knight takes h5 bishop h5
so it even works out there
yeah and he's spending a lot of time
this is actually what got him into
trouble in previous games
where the position is complicated and
that he went too low on the clock and
he's probably thinking do i throw in
rook c1 he does so
queen f5 looks like the only real option
automatic move and i don't think that
inclusion benefits
canty because now knight h5 let's say
takes takes there's maybe
g4 and yeah so he's going to go knight
g3
bishop back to e bishop d1 might
actually be an interesting move i
really like bishop d1 because you go
bishop c2 and take over the f5 square
for your knight
i think he's gonna go rook d1 bishop d3
same idea
bring that knight in and he does yeah
and bishop d3
traps the queen actually oh my goodness
right it looks like you're just trying
to take the f5 square but the queen is
trapped
so queen b1 yeah queen b1 b1 and it hits
the bishop
that's that's game over if he plays
queen b1 wow
i played that that flags
oh my goodness it's that plus one robert
so deceptive that's barely enough time
to register the move and make one of
your own
well can we just bring up that position
again because
that was wild f3 is such a dangerous
move to play because you're opening up
your own king
so we would take that instinctively and
maybe just h4
right right taking advantage of the pin
hitting the knight and all of a sudden
in a time scramble if levy gets those
two moves off
like take this pre-move h4 you've got
yourself a game here
exactly so james really was playing with
fire there
it works out in his favor and as we get
into uh this new game here
i mean it's trumpowski attack so we're
getting obscure
not so obscure but less popular openings
and james is once again up a pawn
but his queen is a niffy spot in the
center of the board
could be attacked many times i think
that levy is just relying on the active
play
and james has been taking what levy's
been giving him so far
yeah that's exactly that's a good great
way to put it is that
james is sitting there saying look
you're gonna play these offbeat openings
against me they're not topped here for a
reason
i'm going to go ahead and take the
material you know give me the material
and you prove
that you know this is crushing for for
you
what we have here is as you mentioned
the trumpowski i think this is a fun
line for white to play so i kind of like
levy's position but
that's just been the story the whole
time levy has had a lot of fun positions
to play with compensation
but james just keeps taking that
material and saying all right prove it
you know i'm gonna
take these all match i think the most
troubling sign for me
is that levy spends a lot of time after
playing these uh openings because when
you
it's a part of it is the surprise factor
when you play something that is not
standard you're relying on that you know
it better and that you will be able to
make
the most quickly so you'll get that lead
on the clock but that has not been the
case
james has been able to meet these
openings with quick responses
and he's playing quite well you know
right out of the gate so
it is concerning for levy as we continue
here is a 2-2 match
but amman justify the pawn sacrifice for
me white is down a pawn
tell me why i should approve of white's
position here
yeah i mean especially after d6 the
if you have d6 e5 against the bishop
like a london bishop let's call it
or a bishop on this diagonal h2 to b8
you're already feeling good because that
bishop's completely blunted there's
nothing going on here h6
uh even covers g5 in this position i
mean
you're just hoping for bishop d3 and and
trying to chase that queen but
you know even if you waste a lot of time
maybe three moves in a row bringing that
queen back the problem is robert we've
got a closed position
and closed positions are exactly where
you can let's say quote unquote waste
time like that or make a bunch of moves
that don't complete your development
if this position was wide open i'd be a
lot more concerned for canteen
completely agreed and the idea for white
is maybe bishop d3 but the queen's not
trapped because you have the g4 square
and now there's a bit of a problem
because the h pawn would like to go back
to h3 there
no can't happen and knight d7 clever
play by
james bishop d3 now met by queen takes
d5
which was not possible before because
there would have been a check discovery
a fossil
if you will and the queen would have
been hanging on d5
yeah no that's exactly right and time
and time again canty just takes the
material and
runs away with it basically and it's up
to levy to to prove this i don't think
he's in a terrible position
this is still you know well within the
realm of
what position you can expect from this
line um he might want to go
queen b3 a4a5 knight d2 or bishop d3
always kick the queen out right
i'm with you man and i think here now
that queen should probably
say my stay has been excellent but i'm
no longer welcome on the e4 square
it feels like if you leave it there too
long bishop d3 will hurt you
especially if you make the move bishop
g4 which looks like a very natural move
then bishop e3 traps your queen on the
spot it's true
that that would be a terrible thing to
do a terrible thing
so probably just castle would be
my move you still always have the g4
squad escape too
um the other thing that's kind of uh
yeah
a5 i was just gonna say after knight d7
you can almost play like
knight takes e5 and bishop d3 trapping
the queen once again
oh no the g2 pawn hangs oh it's so close
oh man so maybe you should throw in like
work
the sneaky no idea what you're doing
with rick h2
exactly yeah don't mind me uh just
look over there for a sec buddy
yeah this is any castles and but by the
way levy is now ahead of the clock we
made a big deal about james has been the
one
up on time throughout the match right
now levy does have quite a substantial
lead on time however he's down a pawn i
don't see
the clear compensation and a big problem
for white is where you're going to
castle
if you cast a king side the only way you
can legally castle now you sort of
regret having your pawn on h4
as your king side is a little bit more
vulnerable and it's a it's actually
really impressive that james is able to
leave his queen on e4
for so long i i just couldn't do it i
would just look at that queen and be
like no
no i'm about to get trapped something's
gonna go horribly wrong here
i'm so scared of these like night triggs
to trap the queen but james says look i
mean it doesn't work
you know just calculate that out those
are concrete calculations and
it looks like he's made them here yeah
and i'm looking at the players right now
james is locked in like he no longer is
seated he is
just fully focused head right at the
computer screen
and this is his chance right he's
probably feeling that that hey i was
down two games to one after losing on
time
now look at this it's 2-2 i'm up a pawn
i know i'm ahead on the clock
my queen's not getting trapped
thankfully so f5 comes to mind for black
in the near future
be very careful here if you are levy
because this position
can get quite bad in the near future but
h5 played
taking away some squares from that queen
and maybe there's a
rook h4 type of idea in the future and
it's fine
levy to also looks locked in like these
guys both look like they're calculating
really really hard right now the problem
is what you're seeing
is james is calculating where he knows
that he probably has the upper hand
things
are sort of going to work in his favor
that's how chess generally works if you
feel you have slightly better position
the tactics
often work for you whereas levy's
calculating like a guy who wants to make
things work he's trying to find the
trickier ways to play and the ways that
candy might slip up yeah and i said this
at the top of the show is that you
cannot play chess
for a result because then you're
distracted you're not being objective
and chess is a very objective game
so if you have results or into thinking
you aren't playing your best chess and
look at this
a trade of bishops here you would like
to get bishop b3 in
very quickly and then put your knight on
f5 but bishop d3 would always be met by
pawn to e4
and maybe e4 now is good for black put
that knight on e5
and just take over the board i agree i
agree f5
i think this move is also playable but
what i don't like
is that that queen robert not to give
you flashbacks but no
queen on h7 knight g6 i mean let's just
say the coffin over here
i see what you did there and you know
you wanted to remind me of what happened
to
my queen when we were playing the chess
com chess bro match but you're right
that
even if knight g6 isn't the immediate
move and levy doesn't play i think it
was smart
to hold back from it you just created
weaknesses for yourself that you're
going to have to
look at move after move and now we're
back to a situation levy a bit ahead in
the clock
he's finally ready to castle if he wants
to and
where is james going from here i think
e4 should be played
e4 trying to get your knight d5 plays
rook f7
and the funny thing about the position
is although levy might be down a pawn
believe me it's going to be a long time
before that matters look at that extra
pawn it's on b7
there's no queen side play to speak of
um this game is all about the king side
and hey the pawns are equal on the king
side so
i think i think uh canty by the way
played rook f7 for knight f8
he did not like knight g6 so he wanted
to be able to remove that piece
when it comes out in fact he might play
knight f8 right away but he might not
like the look of g4 at some moment
probably not now and he plays knight
fade to
allow a trade on g4 and the rook on f7
also protects g7 so you are
making sure that in the event the g-file
opens up you're not just going to get
a blistering checkmate on the square so
i do approve this i think maybe you
should use that extra pawn you mention
it
it's not doing anything at some point
play b6
what
g5 and it's not that it's terrible it's
just
insane i did not see that coming right
that might be a good move though he's
like levy i heard you were trying
to play g4 well sorry buddy i got there
first
wow that is a move and
wow and takes takes first of all it's
important to note that
if everybody takes and you go bishop h5
looking to win material
don't forget that little sneaky check uh
james is not about to drop
material there wow that
is an awesome move we're gonna have to
remember to ask james about this moment
uh that was real i don't even care about
the result that's just
to even think about g5 and that's the
hardest part it's once it's played
you're like oh actually that makes a lot
of sense
but to even think about it during a game
when you have under a minute on the
clock
that's phenomenal stuff and i like his
position all of a sudden oh man the
knights coming to e4 he's flipping this
around completely and the time is
even now in fact it's swinging in
canty's favor
what a brilliant move that is
i am still in shock and as i try to look
at the position as it unfolds here
you said knight f6 can come to e4 or
even to g4 depending on what happens
uh this bishop can develop rook to e8
take over the e file
the white king is not safe no king f2
there's always like a g4 at some point
in queen d4 check
just always have to consider that that
knight is coming straight into e4 and
now that the king's on f1
yup can't take that oh boy and levi
probably underestimated that he was
previously with the king on e1
probably planning to take and where does
that queen even go if you go to the e
file rookie 8 then there's knight
discoveries to win the queen on the e
file this is
i mean you can't just take back takes g5
yeah exactly
my goodness what a game but james canty
wow wow
yeah it looks logical but i mean g4 is
a rookie eight first like hello let's
start with that
because h6 isn't a okay he won't quench
him because he was worried about h6 i
guess but that wasn't actually that
concerning
and james needs to move more quickly
we've seen him throw away
decent positions good positions in time
trouble he's under 20 seconds
and he has been the one who has faltered
when the clock starts dwindling
i don't mind this move queen h6 but he
needs a rook on the e file it's it's
been too long with that one and now
maybe it doesn't even work because it's
queen g5
it takes a quick g5 but queen should we
trade everything is knight trapped
no it's not as the h3 square it's got e6
as well let's say if need be but yeah
you're right yeah there's also each
h3 so he grabs the pawn and it was e3 i
think that james is
in great position look at that move
rookie for winning a c4 pawn
but levy can't complain we saw the
position he previously had
you can't complain with what you got
here no this is
by far the best oh and the rook should
went to the d file i think take on e6
rookie four game over because all pawn
end games are going to be winning for
black
oh i don't love that move but you've got
to be careful yep oh
so e6 hang on c3 is winning on the spot
c3 c2
so take on h6 you're up three pawns over
here oh i don't like that move you
should not let the king come back on
this way
i think levy oh it's close quincy five
so i think this is probably winning
two pawns is i think technically a draw
but there's no way he's gonna have time
to set it up
no and there's also that extra pawn just
in case like i don't know if that
matters
but it could it's a rookie two game over
king a1 don't take it
don't take it don't take that rook a3
that's
that's smart nice try though by levy
that was pretty very nice
and don't play rook b2 because that puts
the king on a stalemate so do not play
i don't like that check check yes nice
nice move
these guys are both playing really well
here yeah they really like c1 intended
you gotta go rook b8 or right
side c3 just push that pawn i think
okay only rook check king e3 oh and king
c1
just what a wild position no no what no
the could you steal me
oh my god rook takes you too it wasn't
it doesn't work anymore oh
what the hell my gosh
what the hell was that oh that
end game must have fluctuated from
winning to
to draw so many times and levy was using
the chess tactic
desperado where the position on the
board is a draw except for one piece
that you have
so you take that piece and you say hey
over here take me
take me pick me okay and eventually he
had to
that was one of the most exhilarating
games i've been a part of
first of all i'm not going to forget
about james candy's g5
that was a stellar move and then you
have to just
say you know what levy rosin with
amazing
awareness of the fact that there could
be stalemates he was
losing that end game for sure but he
found it just in time and
james in time trouble once again that's
been his kryptonite
just insane what a crazy crazy game
that the poor eval bar robert just got
the biggest workout
of the day yeah it's very true
it was swinging up and down real fast
and by the way
i haven't been able to make fun of the
opening choice here because the scandy
i'm sure greg shahadi a participant in
this tournament is laughing about the
scandinavian but we did see a scandi
and that's why levy's queen's in the
center as we get to the current position
and james should be very happy once
again yeah he's got a very
very standard uh very standard type of
position here in c4 queen h5
played yeah can't complain here if
you're candy gotta watch it for a little
trick here bishop takes h2
with the pin on the knight there but h3
covers that
yeah and white just has more space has
two pawns
uh out on the fourth rank none of
black's pieces besides the queen are
past your own third rank
so easy development coming for white i
would much prefer
james's position and so levy will have
to figure this out
on his own here and he's also down and
building the clock yeah
how about that that last game like in
terms of what it means for the players
i feel like levy almost treats that game
like a win like that's how it must feel
he made an insane comeback from like a
dead lost position
and and then yeah it probably feels that
way to him whereas james
knows that he was he was winning that
game and threw it away at the end
yeah and he you saw his face he was
pretty devastated by the fact that he
didn't win that game he could have
gone ahead in this match and what he
needs to do is just look at the position
that he has on the board right now his
position is good
right he has a new game this is good i
didn't like the move c5
because that leaves a hole in the d5
square and leaves you with his pawn on
d4
that is kind of backwards but he says
i'm going to put my bishop on f4
and take advantage of kicking my
opponent's bishop out so he has a good
position that's my ultimate point
he should take a breath just look here
at this game and play as if it's zero to
zero because
it's a time match and what happens
on uh knight takes like is it is it
worth
just full simplification takes takes
takes on c7
and and try to try to go for that
position
bishop h2 he doesn't want to yeah he
didn't want to drop the d4 pawn but i'm
with you that that looked pretty good
i guess he's saying hey please do take
me on c3 because when i take back with
the b pawn your c7 pawn is under attack
my d4 pawn is strengthened and the b
file will be
open for my rook so instead levy smartly
plays bishop
f6 and i expect some kind of just rook
d1
to rick fd1 i guess to defend the pawn
yep one of those rooks to d1 it's going
to be the a brook so in case
the the e file i mean it is a semi-open
file for white so rook
f2e1 is going to make some sense in the
future and canty
uh you know don't forget opening up that
around 30 second time
advantage early on in these games it
might not look relevant right now when
these players have
so much time you know relative to the
the blitz that everyone plays nowadays
but
that 30 seconds if these guys play at
the same pace suddenly it's 30 seconds
when
when the guy has you know 10 seconds to
40 and it means it means the world i'm
with you a nice look at the eval bar it
says that white's slightly
ever so slightly better but from my
point of view here it just seems easier
to play for white i actually don't see
what black's plan is
exactly and a3 why can't try to play b4
it feels like even if it's not
concretely that good for white
it just i'm threatening something it
looks like i'm threatening something
and you're gonna have to deal with that
move after move yep this knight
tied down to that c7 pawn keep in mind
if that c7 pawn just drops for any
reason
the d6 square is gone and black's
position just collapses a hundred
percent
i'm also just looking at that queen and
saying okay you know i just always have
to
be cognizant of the fact that it doesn't
have a lot of squares left on the board
to move to
so you know some type of attacks g4 and
a g3 in the right moment
when things are protected uh could could
put the question of that queen
i'm with you again and i mean i'm
looking at this position
what is black's planet it looked like e5
was what you wanted to
do but that's not happening not with a
knight on f3 a bishop on h2 the pawn on
d4
on the queen and the rook on the e file
so i would probably move my queen away
to make queen c2 queen b3 comes to mind
as a way to just
poke and prod at black's queen side over
there and as you're pointing out the
queen on h5 just doesn't have the same
power and the same access to better
squares
and it's important to know knight takes
f6 check
levees absolutely recapturing with the g
pawn not only because he needs to
protect
c7 but also because i think it's a good
move anyways it covers
the e5 square and it opens a dangerous
chi file
uh to white's king that's definitely
true and the knight on d5 is so powerful
and a light square
it's the entire reason i did not like
when james went c5
because you give your opponent a square
and now you have this pawn on d4 that's
stuck in place so
i think levy's honestly playing this
very well and he's keeping about love on
the clock he's down a little bit but as
we've seen
if he's the one lowering the clock he
still manages to hold on
despite that time deficit so for now
okay i still
am concerned though about how levi's
been using his time
yeah what i think levi should do is make
much quicker moves
um because i i don't think that when
he's played king h8
the thing is look at that eval bar after
king aj the eval bar barely changed
i don't think levy is is at risk of
making a huge blunder of any sort here
so you know just throw in queen f5
throwing queen g6 king h8
uh rook d7 like just just some small
move and and really
get that time on the clock back because
you're looking at laby's position saying
well i don't really know what the guy's
going to do but
at the same time he's got a great
looking position right now so he can
almost just kind of shuffle around in a
blitz sense
you're right and an important point is
rook b3 which i imagine was james's idea
can be met by knight a5 it's a typical
move
that defends your pawn on b7 while
attacking the rook
and that's necessary because you do not
want to drop that pawn
and so it's a clever response available
to
levy there yeah and if james ever gets
tempted by the move b4
it might do him more harm than good
because you don't really need to connect
these pawns
and the pawn on b2 might not look like
it but covering the c3 square
is really important and that's why he
played rook to d3 he wanted queen takes
h3
with some sort of knight move knight e5
hitting the queen
wow james first with g5 now with g4
i don't really like it that he followed
up with knight takes bishop because you
were talking about how black wanted to
take with the pawn of six anyway
and now with the pawn on g4 that becomes
a bit of a target
but i think right now he kind of has to
slide his king to h1
i don't like his king the g5 this this
is a position where i think
levy is extremely happy um he's probably
going to follow up with some sort of h5
or maybe
f5 probably the h pawn slide the rook
over this knight on d5 what a monster
that
you just can't get rid of it well let me
counter this what about some kind of
knight g2 bishop g3 bishop h okay he
went knight f3 back but i was wondering
if that bishop can slide out and try to
get to the h4 square at some point
i really like the move knight g2 just as
an idea to go to f4
maybe to go to e3 as he said bishop g3
plug the g
file with pieces so that it's you know
less of an impact when it gets pried
open with h5
yeah and i see the eval bar favoring
black but i would say it's not
very easy to prove that but rook g8 is a
step in the right direction rook g1
would be
my response because i i see that there's
a queen of rook there trying to open up
the file
i don't want that to happen i can play
rook g1 as a response to f5 or h5
so that's probably why he felt no rush
to
move his rook yeah the rook's gonna
slide over let's see if h5
this knight where is it trying to go
could go to c4 and e3 it could go to
e4 and c3 but i think getting rid of
this knight is definitely a
big idea for canty yeah
i would agree with that and i'm trying
to think do i play queen e4
do i offer queen he puts his knight back
on f3 he feels aimless right now
he went knight h4 knight f3 knight d2
knight f3
and he does not mind making a draw
because he's down on the clock
and his position looks worse to my eyes
but he hasn't
found a plan yet knight takes up six at
some point watch out for that just
maybe not yet in general but the bishop
wants to land on e5 so
interesting idea so something like uh
yeah knight there for example
rook f3 knight h4 rook takes f6 and
bishop e5
a hundred percent you're right three
good yeah and knight h4
it's easy to blunder that rook takes f6
i don't know if it works but it
certainly looks good following your idea
of getting that bishop to e5 with a
sacrifice
i think it does work i mean then you win
a pawn
and a knight for the rook and the king
is weak the rook and g will be under
attack
and i actually don't really know what
black should have
f5 what about f5 takes and knight f4
f5 you're a brave brave guy but you know
yeah maybe can i play queen on f1 at the
end of that like i take
your negative queen f1 i say you're not
checkmating me
yeah i think that has to be it and
actually that could backfire on levy he
has a number of ways to go wrong here
maybe f5 is not the best maybe net h4 is
not the best he goes
e5 of all moves this is going to get
wild at the finish
and look at the time 24 seconds left for
levy 25
seconds almost for james he takes the
pawn now the knight's trying to come to
f4 so be careful about that
but what does knight of four actually
attack you've given up the f5 square so
knight g3 comes to mind
there it is watch out knight h5 knight
five coming
e5 pawn is hanging by the way and he's
trying to bait him in
to queen e5 with a rook d1 at the end
and now b7 is hanging you may not have
seen important but that pawn can be
captured of rook d4 for
example and that knight is coming in the
game
yep in eight seconds oh wow this is
gonna be a crazy finish
and i know levy plays a lot of hyper
bullet but you do not want to be down to
5.8 seconds in this position
he plays f6 knight h5 dangerous move but
he has the g-file under his control with
a rook g201
he does and that that that knight is
going to be hanging
on f4 at the end you can trade
everything here that's a really good
point trade and take on f4 it's a very
good idea
he doesn't do it just yet and levi
barely got that move off with something
seconds left
oh my goodness queen g4 queen e4 oh gosh
that's mata queen takes b7 only move
plus queen of one between e4 no it's
over oh queen takes f6 trick
oh great oh you missed it wow
oh i don't know if it was going to be a
draw there but it looked like great
chances
queen takes f6 bishop e3 the h-bomb's
loose
but it should be a win for levy wow
levy's just
proven to be stronger in time trouble
that's that's
right now that's where this match is at
wow
and he takes it he doesn't want to risk
anything at this point
just don't run your king away too far
because then g5 will win for what
yeah i like c6 by kante you know it
looks
maybe irrelevant but hey that's a chance
at some point
using the outside h-bond he should be
lost here and
levy knows what to do no this is not
going to work the king is in the box
and the king comes back and stops the
bomb yep
apon and the g-pawn are going to run
in chesapeake with the gifted subs
a little bit of celebration there as
well for uh levy rosman
as he takes the lead in this match again
and this might be the last game
of this five minute portion robert yeah
it looks like it will be because they're
under five minutes remaining and these
games have gone a long time and levy
goes back to this variation
where james did seem well prepared he
didn't win the game he uncorked that
really brilliant g5 move that
we were very fond of especially me and i
don't know if i
approve of going back to this variation
what do you think i'm on
um i i think that james is generally
going to be
happy to repeat most of the things that
we've seen in this match
i'll put it that way like i think that
he's been comfortable taking these pawns
i think it's in his style
and i think that obviously we've got a
very close match here robert i think
that
it's working out so he's saying look i
might be you know
dropping a few of these games but i'm
very happy to keep taking the material
and what he knows is that we haven't had
a break since the last game
so it's not like levy has had time to to
check a line or anything like that
um so he knows look the guy is just
repeating the line maybe he'll switch
something up but it's not like he has
any new theory
after a break maybe we'll see him uh
check the line himself
and the guys might change things up but
right now i think he's fine to repeat
yeah and actually i like this version
much more than what happened in the
previous game for levy
because at least he has an aggressive
position that queen on e4 looked
problematic for james but it was somehow
safe in the center
now the queen is back on f6 but look at
white's storming on the king side
so don't be playing bishop to e7 and
castling king side
as g5 will rip that whole side of the
board open and your king
will be in danger absolutely he's just
tickling that b7 pawn saying you know
you can't develop your bishop anywhere
um not that you have a lot of great
options but you're tied down to defense
for the moment
and what he wants to do is just slowly
play like c4
bishop d3 if possible knight you know h3
or e2 and really just slowly get
developed
um i think if all that happens he he has
a very good as you said attacking
position here
and e4 by james canty he's not looking
to let levy
get that slow development that i was
just talking about but he missed that
move i think queen a4
check unless he intentionally did this
but queen a4 picks up that pawn without
ruining white's pawn structure so i'm
going to
venture and say that james just
overlooked that check which is
a nice find by levy there and i think he
did yeah
bishop e7 the pawn c3 though that's
under attack so rook c1 was
you know you won't repeat one i wrote c1
it's a little slow but
yeah it just feels like this had to help
levy's position
for sure um i still think you know
levy's got this strange position where
he's got like four pawns uh flying down
the king's side
and you know an open file to the king in
the middle it's not like if levy castles
his king is getting any more safe
so james probably has the safer king
options for the for the future but right
now
levy winning that pawn back we've seen
how equal or how close this game can be
when levy's down upon now he's got it
back and technically the material is
equal
although i wonder what black does right
now because if you castle king side
there could be g5
and that spells trouble opening the age
file doesn't seem very friendly for
black so i'm wondering if you try to
even play king d8
at some point and slide that rook to e8
and use that to your advantage
yeah the entire queen side is pretty
closed off so
even if the king just sort of hit on c7
i don't think it would be that bad
right and i guess g5 is already a threat
though for white that you have to be
careful about because
black would not be able to capture on g5
as the rook on the h8 is loose over
there so that's a tactic
that i'm now better understanding
and that's something that james is
surely considering
as a response to his next move
definitely and if that queen is not
there bishop d6
well in the current position at least
always hangs so something to
to look out for i wonder if knight e5 is
is a move
so hang on a month let's show this
variation
g5 uh h takes g h takes g
rook h1 and if
gf6 knight f6 how does this play out
right because you've got this hanging
knight
on g1 i guess there there's a check on
a4 but
that could be interesting check on a4
and like queen c2 and queen
h2 oh that's beautiful like trapping the
rook there and ending up with the
advantage
that is beautiful stuff nice find there
so okay so i guess you can't go ahead
and take the
the rook maybe you just have to take on
g5 twice and well you can't do that
either so
ooh he's thinking about g5 for sure
levy is calculating that one out right
now because it looks so strong
right you have to play queen g6 then we
just
process elimination your queen is
trapped otherwise so
i guess queen g6 was enough for levy to
say you know what i'm not going to force
the action there i don't see
a clear conclusion that's favorable for
me let me just stop e5
yeah and i think that's the right way to
go i think the
levy of five games ago might have spent
a lot of time there
gone for g5 and the game would have got
wild anybody got low on time
a4 he's he's up a minute here let's keep
things controlled
stop e5 he's one upon on e4 thanks to
that tactic earlier there's no need to
to push the tempo here
yeah so material is even but the pawns
have been captured not the same black is
a b-pawn white has an e-pawn
and many advanced pawns for levy at this
point
and james yeah he's moving too slowly i
i see
that he's struggling more he's even the
match score and has been playing really
well
but the clock has not been his friend no
no the last couple games have been a
little bit different in those time
scrambles
levy has been truly impressive in uh
which is what we expect from a b5 plate
that is upon sacrifice officially um if
levy wants to take that
i wonder what kante is planning um is he
just gonna castle after that
hey man sometimes you got to go full
toby maguire with the pawn sacrifice but
if the thing is there's rook a1 right so
ab5
a takes bishop takes there's like a rook
a1 move that
tries to distract the rook so the queen
on c uh can take on c3
it's a funny move yeah queen takes c3
and everything gets hit but there's
clearly a problem with it because the
evaluation went really high in white's
favor
you're perfect robert that's a great
line it looked fun
it looked fun exactly these engines
taking the fun out of everything knight
h3 finally a developing move
from levy we haven't seen one of those
in quite some time if you look at how
many puns
he's actually moved every single pawn at
some point that he has on the board
and now james says my turn knight into
e5 i wanted to play c4 and get that
knight into c5 instead but perhaps he
felt
enough time to accomplish that and then
on e5 it does put pressure on the f3
pawn and after bishop takes e5 the h4
pawn is going to be
loose in many different variations yeah
yeah and you got to be careful bishop
takes e5 don't take with the pawn
because there would be d6
hitting the rook on a8 and hitting the
bishop on e7 so
you would have to take back with the
queen there very good point and here
knight f4 is that knight coming just
straight over there to h5 no not yet
because
f3 is hanging so black does have a turn
to say knight h5 doesn't crush me just
yet but it could be
a big problem in the future so he
castles
wow he takes that moment to castle it's
important to note that g5 didn't quite
win that pawn there because white would
throw in rook takes h8 and draw the
queen away
and black castle's here so now he's
looking to probably play bishop e2
and the threat in the night knight to h5
idea
but the good news is black will have
queen g6
maybe there's some kind of bishop d8
bishop a5 the reason i'm thinking about
that is i want to open the e file and i
also want to improve my really bad
bishop on
e7 that bishop is just staring into its
own pieces so
bishop d8 comes to mind at some point
okay this is what i was expecting from
levy he guards that pawn
in tens knight to h5 and it's up to
james how he wants to react he's down
getting close to about yeah 40 50
seconds and he decides to take
so that long term he always has a past
apon and he does have the b file to work
with but
it looks like this game is mainly going
to be decided on the king side here
it's what it seems but perhaps the b
file will come to james's advantage
right if he can just put a rook on b8
and
swing it all the way down to b2 for
example i could see james countering
very quickly
on the queen side if there's no
immediate breakthrough on the king's
side for levy
and then suddenly the the tempo switches
to the other side of the board the time
is evening out a little bit
as you see a quick reply by canty and
suddenly it seems like black has a much
more obvious plan white's position has
looked good in fact it looks almost
dominating but then you're like wait
if i play knight h5 the queen will go to
g6 okay queen's safe there
if i you know play g5 maybe the queen
comes into f5 or i drop a pawn so
there's thought required with every
single move for levy at this point
and it feels like black can try to make
move like f to b8 or pawn to a5
as you were talking about definitely
yeah even
at some point like pawn to c4 you
mentioned earlier and just sacrifice
that knight in on d3 sometimes just
opening the position we talked about how
levy's king is not the most safe uh on
e1 g5 played we do have a response that
takes and queen f5
i think is what james is going to go for
and levy will probably e4
just give up the g5 pawn and go for the
attack on the king side
but perhaps that that rook on b8 will
come in handy
down the line here because at some point
you can use it to
attack the queen and try to create
threats of your own
yeah she decides to take it e4 to follow
it's bishop bishop i don't really want
to play bishop h7
because that gets it trapped so he goes
this way but i'm worried about the h
file like can rook on c1 land on h8
somehow
that exactly that would be a checkmate
very hard to get out of f6 there's
always g6
yeah but g5 is hanging for the
foreseeable future
and i don't see a way to protect it yeah
not i mean
bishop h4 you're not happy to play that
move and then let's not forget about
that eight pawn we mentioned earlier
30 seconds now to 14 ticking down he's
got more than double the time of levy
he does this is our final game of the
five minute portion as the match clock
has expired rook b2
looks just play that move bring that
rook into the game
then bishop b5 comes to mind he takes
the pump at f4
take it wow he's going straight for it
and this has been the theme the entire
match robert he takes the pawns that
levy offers
but knight f6 check here oh he doesn't
play it but i thought knight f6 was a
possibility there
to distract
oh my goodness he's blundering this yeah
left and right unfortunately in the top
two seconds and he's just a five eight
what about that a pawn
yeah let's not forget a five four three
two one and he is just trying to create
threats with e6 and i like it but it
should not be taken and it isn't by
canty
just now start taking the pawns yeah a3
don't mind if you do right yeah i think
you can just push push push here
and even bishop b5 just just a final
move to cover
and he says i don't need it a2 rook to
b1 or rotates e7
67 nicely done he gets a queen and
there's no checkmate
on e8 so nothing really to worry about
there i'm trying to invent a checkmate
2.7 seconds rookie 2
is classy as well everything is hanging
made on the board
and we are actually going to go into the
break after the five minute portion
tied robert did you expect that coming
into this match at all
no i didn't and while i certainly
respect james kane iii
is a fantastic player i didn't quite
expect him to be able to keep
level in the longest time patrol we've
seen time and time again the stronger
player with more time in the clock tends
to take the lead
but canty has come prepared he has come
emotionally pretty stable yes
he was devastated at points when he
didn't win certain games but he was able
to bounce back and that final game right
there
to not just you know get out of control
you blundered upon the center he said no
i got this
we got this we're moving forward james
cannon the third is locked
in and he's an even match with levi
rosman yeah
super super impressive uh gotta give
credit to
canty now levy also wiggled its way out
of some insane positions i'm just
remembering the stalemate that we saw
from him
and i think i mentioned this at the
beginning of the match but i feel like
the story
is going to be basically how impressive
can levy be in time pressure because i
don't think he's changing anything in
his style it's just built in
he's going to get low on time he's so
impressive in those time scrambles but
is he going to be able to do that
enough of the time when canty's out
there just taking pawns left and right
and saying hey
show me the win show me the win it's
going to be very interesting to watch
and the shorter time controls
whether that time disadvantage that levy
seems to be getting into that pressure
is that going to affect the shorter time
controls more
it's a question we'll have to let the
players answer and they should be
looking at their openings because
it feels like they can catch each other
there especially with the
lower time limits here however we're
going to take a break i'm going to grab
some water i'm on
you do your thing we will be back in
just a few minutes with more action from
this levy rosman
james kane iii i'm now gm speed to
championship match brought to you by
chess.com
well of course we still have more action
from this matchup between
gotham chess and jim canty but we want
to remind everybody of pogchamps 3
coming up
in mid-february presented by grip6 and
other
great sponsors it's going to be another
fun one with the likes of xqc
code miko ludwig and more amman
that one's going to be fun but i just
can't get this match
out of my head the way that these two
players have gone back and forth
taking the lead then the match is even
up once again what to make of all of it
thus far
i know it's been a wild ride there's
been um
leads left right and center but there
has never been uh
either player just jumping out to some
crazy lead
and and leaving the other guy far behind
it's been a very close match it feels
like as soon as
one of these players gets a win their
opponent comes right storming right back
with
uh with win the next game so
you don't get to see any anything like a
blowout some people thought maybe
you know international master versus
national master uh blowout in the five
minute portion
not at all what we're seeing here is a
very close match and levy's going to
need to make some adjustments
if he wants to take this match home i
think he's probably still the favorite
and
after a you know tumultuous five minute
portion i don't think he's gonna be too
upset being tied
but uh james canty on the other hand
he's probably feeling himself and
he's reminding people that he came to
play and for those you know for the
doubters for the for the canty doubters
out there
he is he's showing them why uh you know
he's he's in this tournament
yeah nobody should be doubting him
anymore especially after that
performance
tied three and a half three and a half
among you and i were talking before the
show
uh when we looked up his stats he
actually performs quite well
against title players i mean he gets ims
i think it was something like 145 wins
to 170 losses
in his blitz history on chess.com so he
can score victories over these players
and today he's proving just that yeah
it's a very impressive stat line uh you
know someone at the national master
level to be
you know basically have a slightly
losing record against iams and even
grand masters
is is insane that's that's super
impressive and i think some of the chess
that he's shown today
is is a tribute to that so here we go
with
uh looks like the scandy we're back to
this uh canty against
rosman do you like the idea from i guess
either player to go back in this opening
i always prefer the white side of the
positions against the scandinavian john
bartholomew i hope you're watching
because hashtag teamscandy we'll see if
it lasts but right now
uh levy goes back to it he did win the
game with the scandinavian it was a wild
affair where both sides are chances
but right now i just like the pawns c4
and d4
there's ease of access for white's
pieces development comes naturally
i have to prefer kenny's position well i
was going to ask you and he played it
before i could get to the question
do you like his take with c5 on the
position because this is a very unique
way of playing you like this pawns on c4
and d4 but
canty really seems to want to play this
position
every single time with c5 getting bishop
f4
for his bishop um getting on that
diagonal hitting the c
pawn and you know it does give up that
that square on d5 do you think it worked
out last time like he's repeating it as
if it was uh he was happy with it
kind of feels like james gained a tempo
though because that knight was on c6 and
the pawn was on
a7 for the time being so doesn't it feel
like
james is just tempo head the knight d5
doesn't work anymore because you just
take on d5 and win the c7 pawn and your
d4 pawn doesn't hang
and that might be just a small small
thing that he may have checked in the
break and said look
i kind of liked my position last time
but why don't i just do the same thing
um
up tempo now i mean i'm gonna need some
convincing here uh robert
why can't i take that bond on c7 yeah
explain that to me i was going to ask
you the same question bishop takes you
i got you i got you i asked you first
like
that that's a free pawn and then just
play bishop anywhere
and bishop h2 was the choice you're just
up a pawn here
that's what it looks like i mean no
doubt there is going to be some pressure
and you can see like that d-pawn is
going to be targeted by levy but
that's the exact same way that the
previous game worked except there was a
pawn on c7
right and you made this point when that
pawn was on c7
if black moves the knight from f6 in
comes the knight to e4
and then to the d6 square so this looks
really bad for levy who's just down a
pawn
and how is he going to drum up com
compensation i
don't see it i get that the d4 pawn
looks like it's under attack
but you really are just down the pot
yeah and the move knight like i think
he's probably gonna take this
uh maybe just go knight e5 he goes
knight e4 he wants that d6 square
but basically if the queens get traded
the only trick i can see
maybe happening in this position is some
sort of pin on the d
file with bishop takes c5 with a loose
rook there after a queen exchange on e2
but
i'm reaching i'm reaching here robert
just trying to
try to find some ideas in levy's
position and i mean look at this queen
on e4 the knight can't move from d5 you
drop b7
one idea for james going for his knight
e5 knight to c4 i think
okay so he plays b6 which invites pawn
takes pawn
but maybe after knight takes he says all
right you have an isolated d-pawn
trading off some of the queen-side
materials is beneficial but there could
be a queen b7 at the end of that
yeah queen b7 i mean let's be clear
that's a pawn i think he's got to go
back to d5 but it's so
candy in this match to take all the
pawns that he's offered
so he's going to do that i mean this is
obvious yo also there's knight d5 rook
e5
rook takes d5 and then you win the bish
27 that's happening
look at him look at this guy go look at
that boy
oh man that's very impressive he's not
settling for the pun
he's incredible right now the shape that
he is in this match
really is something yep super impressive
so he's got two pieces for the rook
definitely favors canty and don't forget
he's even got an extra pawn that he took
a while ago so
he is he's doing very well here and levy
is gonna need
a miracle to to get back in this game
and queen d3 would hope to be that
miracle but the thing was
it wouldn't have worked out you're
trying to get a background checkmate
white would have thrown in
queen takes e8 check first and
distracted the work from the c file so
here just rook f1 good move
this knight can come into e5 the d5 pawn
is hanging just move your bishop away
to give the king some space and this
should be a very easy conversion
honestly
for james and don't forget about this
bishop a lot of people forget that it
controls the b8 square it's just so far
away but if white
you know gets attacked rook d8 he can go
queen b7 hitting both pawns keeping a
watch
on his b2 pawn and it can't be kicked
away on c7 or on b8 so it's very safe on
b7 there
for sure so this is i don't even know
95 should just win f7 bishop g3 queen
takes f1
oh that is that is so so nasty
what he wants that's what he wants yeah
95 closes the e file so queen f1 yeah
i just take it my king can run to e2 f7
is currently hanging
so very very good play by canty he feels
like right when he needs to be accurate
he
pauses he's not playing too instinctive
like bishop g3 a lot of people might
whip out that move like oh yeah that
gets my king the h2 square i'm safe
not at all no and now just move the
queen away
somewhere anywhere queen d7 back because
the knight can't be captured as the rook
on c8
needs that rook on e8's defense yeah
okay queen
awesome great move for sure knight f7 to
d6
is the current threat um knight g6 is
always on the cards
and he goes back to g8 happy with the
draw
is levy in this position as you can see
that eval bar it's it's practically
going for a touchdown trying to trying
to touch the eighth ring
and i think that bishop g3 is just the
move that you need here to make sure
your
king never gets in any danger he doesn't
queen f7 he probably
wants okay goes queen f5 and wanted a
different square for the queen
and at long last he look and say okay
i can breathe now i have the two minor
pieces for the rook i also have that
extra
pawn my king is safer i'm up 30 seconds
everything's going right for candy in
this game and i think he might just go
king g8 back
canty knees bishop g3 and and i think
levi needs to go
king g8 here so there's rook f8 watch
out for it
queen takes that to check watch out for
that kind of background checkmate
whoa that's so tricky from levy and i
think canty
once again looks like he's taking his
time if he doesn't spot that that could
be a nasty puzzle rush win
but i think he has to spot it because
the only move that would lose a queen g4
for example so
that okay he was knight of seven oh
smaller checkmate attempt that was
wow that was clever and he can take a
queen trade here and i think he probably
should just for
the simplicity of the position he might
look for more but
that's already enough he can play knight
h6 first take the queen at any point
i don't like how he's spending his time
here though he's proven to struggle
in time travel so does knight g5 check
protects his queen
and the queen trade is happening levy
trades him and the knights come to d4
and that's a nice square for that knight
bishop next
okay everything looks controlled bishop
f4 to e3
or bishop e5 and f4 and he's got the
setup here
levy's in trouble everything protects
everything here
it's the perfect configuration of pieces
this is seven coming
knight up five can be played to pile up
oh this is just
i mean you couldn't ask for a better
situation for a clinical
client it gets that move off like at the
buzzer
and it's not going to help right bishop
g
should be a checkmate yeah that king is
running up to h4
and it's actually going to be king h5
king g6 looks the
most convincing yeah nice and
there has to be a checkmate here rookie
7 bishop f6 he plays all right the king
is
going to have to run to c8 oh rookie six
and there's
trade runners rookies okay e6 bishop d8
wait um oh that works protect on e3
that's protected i was like oh no
but okay hey moves g takes h5 he knows
what's up he knows what's up
oh my gosh james kenny up can we talk
about james candy for a second like what
are we seeing here this is an insane
performance from what i think it's fair
to say a lot of people
are gonna call him the underdog on paper
and i'm in that group as well
um this is really impressive by kante
and did he did he look at this as well
is he changing this from e5
i thought e5 was good for him he says no
i've looked at this maybe in the break
e6 is better and he plays e6 and levy
did that thing
where you pause because you don't expect
the move but you don't want to let your
opponent know that right so you
you pause for a second and then make a
pretty quick response anyway
but james is the one switching it up
he's the one with the lead
he's the one who's honestly to my eyes
he's kind of been playing the better
chess today
so he should be confident but you need
to settle down both players need to
settle down
because levy at the end of the day he's
the international master he
throughout his history has been the
stronger player between the two he of
course
can catch up and he's proven especially
as we get to the quicker time patrols
that in time trouble
he has been the stronger player so i
think both sides they can
take their pluses thus far and not get
ahead of ourselves because there's a
long match ahead
there certainly is and i think it's fair
to say correct me if i'm wrong
we haven't seen a lead in this match of
more than one point so
if this if this game swings in kante's
direction
that could be the first sort of sizable
lead that uh
that levy is gonna have to deal with
yeah and that's
tough on the emotions and we talked
about this from the top of the show is
that
when you are the favorite there is
pressure on you whether
you want it to be there or not like
people expect you to win
you expect yourself to win you're not
playing the kind of casual comfortable
chess you would
if you're just playing someone who's at
your level or even stronger than you are
so
i think candy has been thriving in this
environment and right now
even on the clock i do like white's pawn
structure and d6 especially that's a
gonna be a fake
f6 bishop d3 the queen gets trapped
i guess there's bishop c3 check can't
forget that that
move inserted but i think it's still
good for for white there
yeah and bishop de that seems smart the
bishop come to a5 with check the queen
is the f6 square or the e6 square
in the event of bishop to d3 the king on
e1
is kind of safe but as this game
continues i could see it getting in some
trouble
yeah and i don't think that levy's upset
playing king f2 like if bishop a5
happens it might be in his plans to play
king f2
without the check so i think he's okay
with that and look at night before
that's threatening knight c2 check so
you
probably have to move your king away
otherwise you play rook h2 but i don't
like the look of rook h2
yeah rook c1 king f2 both look pretty
reasonable the knight if it gets kicked
out eventually by a3
always has the c6 squares it's going to
reroute back to the center of the board
yeah that's the one really bad thing
about playing d6 while it
just keeps that bishop on c locked in
and can't you black can't play d6 you
give up the c6 square
and the diagonal because so b6 followed
by bishop b7 maybe
b5 if you want to rush it but i don't
love the look of b5 as c5
also becomes weak after that yeah b5
very committal
um for sure that's a move that we've
seen from levy uh
in the other opening that we've seen a
lot of today in the the kyrokan but
in this position it looks like a bit of
a reach and i think we'll see king f2
almost immediately there it is yeah and
i wonder if
james wants to play b6 but didn't like
the look of his bishop on d8 so he if he
plays b6 now at least his bishop
is over here on a5 quote unquote active
it's not really doing anything
definitely yep knight e2 just developing
here
for levy i mean a3 is always there to
kick the knight back but he's probably
saying look like
i don't really need to do that if i
don't have to
g5 now that the rook is protected on h1
you can't take that
on white will play h takes g5 and even
if you throw in rook h1
um probably you can play g takes f6 and
f takes g7
which would be a crazy line you know
just as i was saying that canty was
playing
the better chess today this is a great
game by levy this far it seems like
he's just in charge from the very start
and this queen on f5
that's a when it's in trouble knight g3
comes to mind let's kick that queen with
a tempo
because e4 similar let's kick the queen
ooh yeah this is for where does this
queen
go by the way yeah h5 i mean we've seen
that queen on h7 before but i'm not
they're sure
by the way the queen is trapped
regardless of if you take that or not so
king f8
oh man this is just gruesome and that's
the
that's a ko as they say yeah
it's about resign time and if you're
james you probably want more games in
the longer time patrols
so yep yeah that resignation very very
nice there he
he basically got into a position that i
think
after he played d6 don't know if it was
the best move
but i like the idea of d6 cramping the
position and taking it
into uh i guess a position we've never
seen before in the match
and as much fun as i make of the french
defense which is what levy is playing i
think it's a very good choice for him
to not keep going into these
scandinavians or these caracons where
james has proven to
get good positions so look at this a
quick castle queen side watch out for
the move d4 to d5
that can be a problem for black in many
of these positions especially their king
still in the center
so this is already a fascinating
looking position but can't be seemingly
prepared based on how quickly he's
played
yeah both of these guys seem to know
what's going on they eval bar right in
the middle
and i mean white always has some slight
advantage here often you bring the
knight back to
c3 on these lines and maybe go for a
quick d5 move but
i'm wondering what af because he put the
bishop on d5 like after knight c3s he
almost planned to go like
c6 like i'm wondering what his
intentions are there yeah he probably
would have played c6 and said you know
you'll take my bishop we'll have
opposite colored bishops
but at least my pawn structure looks
better
and so kenji just says i'm going to
slide my king over to b1
and now you have to find some moves c6
was played even though the bishop's not
under attack
knight c3 is possible pretty much
whenever so there's no
rush to play it but what is the plan
here
and what is the plan for both sides
honestly well it'd be nice to kick the
bishop out
like b3 c4 uh always comes to mind but
b3 is kind of well met by b4
and you can never play c4 without
dealing with el paso there
um so it's hard to kick that bishop out
hey he might need to just bring that
knight back anyway and he does
so i think levy is already kind of happy
with the opening the way this knight is
just bouncing around
yeah and black is going to play knight
d7 knight b6 trying to bring that knight
into the attack
so i would agree with that i think that
black is much more comfortable with the
position
that you have now versus some of the
other ones you can get in this variation
of the french
and if i am james i'm probably going to
take this bishop
and then move my knight and i want to
get my bishop to h5 it's a common
plan against this pawn structure because
the f7 square
can be a bit of a nuisance to deal with
yeah like if
if black ever wants to castle queen side
suddenly bishop h5 not only can you not
advance that pawn
but that pawn on f7 how do you defend it
with the pieces you have you have to
stick a rook on f8 basically leave it
there the whole game
yeah and well james doing the sensible
thing bringing
his pieces towards the center he's done
that all match he is slightly ahead in
the clock but about level on time thus
far
and well for levy it's decision time do
you play knight to b6 do you
castle queen side which is not unsafe
for the king but we did mention that f7
pawn that's one that i would try to go
after if i were james kennedy
not the not the worst thing there's also
bishop b4
um which puts pressure on the knight uh
pins it and i mean if you could take it
obviously a2 would be hanging
right so he does go knight b6 i like
your idea with knight d2
i mean we were talking about the bishop
gained h5 but the knight could also get
to beat
he goes knight h4 that's that has to be
the wrong side of the board
i mean you see what he's looking at
right like he he sees these knight f5
tricks
and with his rook on e1 i think he was
kind of setting that up for a few moves
but
it does seem like like it shouldn't work
and black's attack is actually the more
dangerous one
yeah bishop b4 he played it and you have
to play a3 now because bishop takes c3
follow-up queen takes a2 check is a
deadly threat so
you're getting a bad pawn structure
knight a4 at the end as well
wait knight d5 uh well
i mean there's no queen move here that
attacks anything relevant i think
so that is yeah if queen c1
can you play knight c3 check does that
work probably why not
n3 takes takes a3
a3 just barely saves the day king a2
yeah but
i mean no harm no foul taking that
material
but you know what's interesting about
this is that white's position does start
to feel safer despite being down the
material so you give up material
you're unhappy about that levy's
position for sure is better but look at
the clock situation so
levy is spending his time here whereas
we're talking about you can take a
clean exchange with bishop dixie one
he's trying to figure out the tactics
and maybe he will play knight c3 check
because that was my first instinct as
well
i mean just go for checkmate instead of
the material yeah he might even be
looking at like
bishop c3 or just some wild moves like
there's so many things to consider here
but at the end of the day look at how
much time he's spent and he has gone for
it a3 has to be on the board he only
moves his top queen
to b4 check and then a3 if black plays
b4 there's bishop c4 king a2 as you were
mentioning
i i don't know if this is gonna get
crazy and remember he used all his time
to do this so
if it doesn't work out he could be in
big trouble here but i see the
evaluation bar drop
like crazy and i don't know why i know
why queen d5 checked first
yeah yes queen d5 was huge but now it's
transposed back
into the other line with bishop e3 this
is not clear at all
this is actually not good for black
because now actually the king on a2 is
safe because
that pawnee 3 is the shield it's an
umbrella pawn and now the material is
such two minor pieces for the rook that
a3 pawn will fall
later in this game not good no this is
not good he's going to run that a pawn
a5 a4 that's what he wants to do
but canty is the one getting his pieces
involved here
and look at the clock situation 5.6
seconds left for levy
and plenty of time for james 27
checkmate if you take the rook so
i love that move queen a3 and he can
just
take on eight four no he takes the
bishop one a four yeah i was saying
wow brave move well two minor pieces
better than a rook yep
knight e3 or knight g3 bishop back to b3
bring the king back in the center
um i think canty two can take that pawn
as well
don't get mated d5 yeah that's what to
worry about
so d5 looks like a great move played by
canty he finds those moves when he needs
to
and 1.7 seconds levy's barely getting
some of these moves off but
he's really proven like he can play
these bullet
scrambles yeah bishop b5 takes on d5
careful tactics available and candy is
plenty of time so he knows he's winning
he just needs to d6 now now
yeah and if rook d4 takes takes knight
takes f5 d3
looks a little bit tricky still he's
probably considering what
the repercussions are should be winning
for white he's got two connected pawns
the knights there as well
yep and d7 first that way the bishop
can't be captured the
queen played bishop oh 95 check 95 wins
in the rook yeah 95 minutes
the game bishop f3 or bishop a4 and the
accuracy from kante when he needed it
there
starting with queen a3 queen c1 takes a3
and it is now
five and a half to four and a half so
right after a crush from levy rosney
traps canty's queen and arguably the
the most decisive match or sorry most
decisive game of this match
candy comes right back and says oh no no
you're not getting on a streak here
against me
and look at this levy goes for oh sorry
james didn't play
knight e4 like he has been instead he
plays queen to b6 so
james did not like that previous game he
switches the opening up
but i tend to like these positions from
the white side but what james is trying
to do is just
lock the board down and say i'm gonna
hold a passive worst position
you have to prove that you can win i'm
ahead in the scoreboard
yeah and and i feel like we've almost
seen this position
without the b2 pawn so levy's got to be
happy
yeah right he gets to keep even material
and now moves like b4
are on the docket for white h5
very interesting i i'm not sure yeah and
you mentioned b4
it's out there and if b takes c5 happens
i mean you gotta move the queen first of
all but after bc5
again it's like there goes the b puns so
basically white's missing the b-pod that
he's missed in every single game they
played this the black's suddenly missing
a d-pod
yeah this is sort of strange to me i
would say
james has been playing very well and
this game doesn't quite make sense
because
he didn't like what he was getting
there's something about it that was
uncomfortable he did get crushed in that
previous game as levy's best game of the
match
but then he goes to this which is just
pretty clearly
objectively bad for black yeah white you
can see the eval bar
plus two and a half and let me tell you
guys white's not up anything
material wise two and a half evaluation
that's almost like a knight or a bishop
being up at night without actually being
up at night means your position is
really really good yeah although that
can mislead people to think especially
if you're
newer to chess oh well white's
completely winning well prove it right
there's
you're not even up a single piece it's
not actually clear how you win this game
but we can tell you one idea for white
is knight d2 knight c4
put that knight on that great square
where it attacks the bishop it attacks
the center
c5 is weak e5 is weak white can play
pawn to f4 to explode the position
with the king sitting on f8 this is
really really bad yeah i think after
knight d2 knight c4
the the nasty thing is you follow up
with a5 and then even
play knight a4 after that and with the
knight pressuring the d6 bishop and the
knight on a4 pressing the c5 pawn
there's no b6 to stabilize and i think
things just fall apart not to mention
that bishop on c8 it's got nothing to do
after black plays g5 you can always mute
it with f3 and just lock everything down
i mean look at the bishop on b8 bishop
and c8 rook on a
they have not come to play this game and
black is trying desperately to play g5
g4 so i would not have
even allowed that probably i would have
put my own bishop on g5 to stop the pawn
from getting there
but where's the attack it seems like
you're trying to wish an attack into
existence but
you're not actually getting one no this
is this is tough after d6 i mean just
look at those three pieces
robert c-88 those are the guys that come
into the
basketball gym with their their duffel
bag to play pickup ball that are too shy
to ask to play or something
i mean those poor guy oh knight e8 as
well
there's a whole bench of them and more
coming you know
it's already there are 15 people and
they're switching out teams but
more of them come on bring your friends
and yeah this is
this is bad i mean i'll just get that
knight to h8 somehow for style points
i'm willing to give you like point two
of a point if you can
make that happen you know oh gosh yeah
the reinforcements are here this is so i
will point out robert i think this is
the first
game just positionally speaking where i
think i'd like to point out just the the
difference in title i think this is
levy showing his item title um in a
positional format there's been so many
tactical games between these guys but
start to finish from this game right
here levy is is showing some really
really good chess
and it's the second game in a row with
the white pieces that levy has been able
to just kind of
squish all of james's chances
from the start of the game so there's
something in this trapowski attack that
james struggles with and i'm sure we're
going to get a break relatively soon and
he will need that break to study this
opening e5 falling i mean this
this is just there's no attack happening
here uh
up a minute let's not forget it's not
like levy is you know
playing all these moves and then he's
down on time again no he's up a minute
he's crushing on the board
he certainly is and this is our final
game before we
take a break it's a halfway point in
this time patrol and i think it comes at
a great time for james and for levy
you're like well now i'm feeling it like
this is the chest that i've been playing
my whole life
hasn't necessarily shown throughout the
earlier stages of today
but this is gotham chess at its finest
absolutely king h1 just taking that
extra moment i mean
you want to take this knight but their
follows bishop takes h3
so just getting out of trouble and james
plays bishop takes h3 this is what we
call
desperation robert there's no other way
to describe it this does not work but
his position was drawing dead
so he's just throwing it out there and
he's hoping that after gtx h3 queen c8
levy forgets that his d-pawn can move
because d7 just cuts off that queen from
the attack but what you need to do
is get your queen over there so hey well
now queen c8 becomes more of a threat
so keep an eye on that d6 falls with
check though so there there's just like
queen takes d6 right now it's good queen
d6 bishop c5 yeah just
yep that would have been a nice little
lights out um
maneuver there it only wins the pawn but
it simplifies the game
i think rook d1 is is just crushing here
yep and okay he he's now
closed down any hope for a king side
attack he is up a full piece
levy rosman gotham chess is going to
take this one for sure
yep there's no no doubt in my mind he's
got this game
the king's on h1 it's out of danger i
mean james just doesn't have enough
pieces to
uh contribute to a meaningful attack
here and f3 says yeah
if you even thought about sacking on g4
it's not happening
no and you know even if you do it i have
the reinforcements i need
to work he just says no rook b6
and i think we might see resigns here
yeah
it's about that time isn't it just take
on c6 rook f6 check and then take the
work on d2
rook takes c7 if you want some extra
points rook f6 if you want even more
extra points
and just the rook goes bye-bye and
result
wow that was a demolition that really
was a one-sided affair
and levy flexed on james and i think
you're right amon that
he used his wealth of experience right
he has that i am titled he has
played so much great chess he started
the game very thoroughly
he just squeezed the life out of james
position
yeah you you said it well there's
there's no other way to put it basically
the last two games that we've seen from
levy
have been crushes and they've been with
the white pieces so
james is gonna have to go into this
break and really evaluate
what's been going wrong in those games
because we haven't seen that the whole
match so
all of a sudden what's maybe concerning
for uh james candy the third is that
when he's losing games uh with the black
pieces they're happening really quickly
and he's kind of getting crushed so he's
gonna have to go reevaluate
levy on the other hand once he
stabilizes with
uh the black pieces i mean we could see
a
blow up match with the way he's been
playing with white for sure if i'm james
all i'm doing in this short break is
looking at the black side of this
trompowski
attack just trying to figure out a line
that makes me feel more confident
because right now
it is not working out but with mom and i
are going to take a break we will return
shortly with more coverage of this
gotham cantee i'm not gm speeches
championship match
and as we return getting ready for more
three minute plus one second increment
time patrol games we have to enjoy that
the match is tied up
five and a half five and a half for
those of you who root for the underdogs
james canyon iii came to play and amman
what do you think going forward here
after james just suffered a pretty
brutal defeat
to levy rosman i think that uh
james is probably happy to have that
break the last
two games that he had the black pieces
in uh let's say bluntly he got crushed
and we haven't seen that in this match
so far so i think he's really happy that
he gets
to take time to regroup check those
games over maybe
and say look what went wrong in those
games that wasn't happening the rest of
the match
so i think he wanted that break and levy
probably a little bit upset he you know
he was just starting to find his rhythm
and his momentum
he just got a crushing win and all of a
sudden the guys are on break so
we're going to come back from this break
and we'll have to see how it affects the
players but i think that kante was was
happy to just
you know revamp after that last game
yeah
you know he gets to look over his
openings both with the black color where
he's struggling against the trowsky
attack
and then with the white pieces he now
needs to figure out is levine continue
playing the french is he going to go
back to that cairo khan and we'll get
the pan off again
will he go for the scandinavian which we
saw a couple of times and for levy
you know he can say hey i've been
playing better chess as the match has
gone on
that should bode well for my chances in
the bullet and well we have the answer
scandinavian it is
yep and once again knight f6 and we're
gonna see this line repeated
i don't think that i mean levy's gotten
some results
in this line but i don't think canty can
be too upset i mean he played a
crushing game last time but levy has
probably also looked at that move order
yeah and well we see that e6
now james is thinking he's down
10 seconds why we ever seen him spend so
much time and
he's had this position before so i
wonder what's happening that caused him
a moment of pause there and levy goes
bishop before and
i think that what um what's been
happening
is that kante is like he's playing this
position again
and he's kind of pausing because he's
like wait a minute why is levy
why does he want to go for this again
these have been good positions for me
and he's maybe just pausing and thinking
should i change
things up because maybe he looked at
this in the break in the end
he goes for c4 and bishop b4 check
is kind of the new idea by levy instead
of bishop d6
and he takes which gives white these
double pawns
but the semi open b file to work with
only white has a dark square bishop
which can be used on f4 or g5 later in
the game
and one of the big questions as always
do you just castle and give up the c3
pawn
i would i i would say yes yeah i
wouldn't spend much time on it i would
castle
canty has done that i personally don't
think levy is going to take that pawn
um but we'll see he could have a
different strategy coming in
uh he castles it's just too risky you
take on c3 you do win a pawn for the
time being but white his moves like
bishop b2
and pawn d5 and the board opens up it
was black's king that would be in danger
so instead
he simply castles rook to b1 is a good
move and that rook can slide up to b5
and then swing to the king's side which
is probably why levy protected b7
with the queen yep yeah if you play b6
then basically you give this exact same
move but with a tempo
right and well where is levine developed
at night i would
want at first glance i would have wanted
to play knight b to d7 knight to b6
but with that rook on b5 like well what
am i really gaining
from this maneuver yeah and a knight on
b6
i mean even if you play queen a4 to
somehow attack that pawn there's always
c5 and that that pawn of b7 ends up
hanging so
canty already off to i would say a good
start he's got this rook b5 idea
and careful on that king side because
there could be a lot of firepower
knight e5 to g4 and as you mentioned
robert that rook swinging over could be
the theme of this game yeah that's
it's a dangerous position but h6 play
just ain't no rook to g5 no bishop to g5
you would like to put your pawn on g5 if
you're white but g4
seems to hang a pawn on the square there
so i don't think you can get away with
it but you
it gives you a hook is my essential
point right
um lots of moves for white here rookie
one bishop f4 even nike five
they all look very reasonable uh h6 i
think
is important to stop that rook from
swinging over to g5 but
one of the reasons that white's attack
could be so successful in this game
is that queen on a6 so far away from the
king it can't really get
over to help with defense um as james
is thinking a lot here robert actually
what you just said inspired me g4 it is
you take me on g4 i'll play h3 king h2
or h1 rook g1 and
maybe instead of h3 just king h1 and
rook g1 and just go for the attack
whoa
talking about going for the attack here
like what's the follow-up is he playing
queen
e5 to g3 with some knight sacrifice like
what's on the cards here queen e3 and
after king there is it gonna be knight
g5 takes rook takes with me
oh my goodness that seems to be what
he's going for
and if if you start with king g7 maybe
there's
g5 check where you give up your rook and
then your queen slithers in there and
wins the knight on f6 and that king is
in
real danger on the hill yep and
and keep in mind that the initial
sacrifice the computer is probably like
whoa whoa whoa
whoa and now it's creeping back to equal
when you sacrifice a piece and you're
attacking the king
and it's equal you've done something
right
a hundred percent and king g7 was in
fact played
moves like 95 are tempting as in
addition to that rook g5 check
rook g5 king h7 where's the
where's the crushing factor because if
you don't
find something concrete you have given
up a piece for just one pawn
yep absolutely brook g5
takes takes king h8
take on f6 at least a draw there
yeah and if king h7 okay he goes for
this and i think this is absolutely
correct
what an attack so far 34 seconds he just
he just punches it in there's plus one
second increment but
if if levy gets low on time here
defending a crazy attack like this is
not
what you want to be doing not at all and
actually maybe after king h7
you just play rook g3 with the idea
being you're gonna play rook h3 next and
there really is an attack here knight e5
comes to mind queen d3 check you have so
many different options
and playing against this attack it's too
scary
especially in a blitz game absolutely
agree i feel like the eval bar is like
yeah it's a draw guys go figure it out
i'm taking the day off you know like
i can't i've done enough swinging in
this match like there's no way i can
calculate
all this no and that's the thing about
this is this happens to
grandmasters plenty right there are
openings played and then someone makes a
sacrifice
because you didn't leave your engine
going for long enough it doesn't see
that deeply
and that sacrifice works out even though
you thought it wouldn't so i think here
rook g3 to start makes sense and one
important
point to note is if black plays rook g
and takes on g3
white will take with the f pawn to open
up the f-file another avenue of attack
yeah brook g3 and like knight e5 queen
e5 he wants to take on f6 but hello
knight d7
i think he forgot that he's gonna go
queen g3
and try to take but now it's not working
for sure
no he forgot knight d7 and this is this
could be a win for levy
a big defense and we'll see because the
king is still really unsafe he plays
rookie that is a smart move
he doesn't think of the tactics two
pawns for the piece but that's not
enough here
no queen c6 threatening queen f3 has to
be queen f4
and queen takes c4 g4 also looks good
and levy down to 7.8 seconds but at some
point i should say
james near the same so this anything can
happen in the time scramble but levy is
just
up material he's up material yeah h3 by
white
is probably a move you want to throw in
just necessary
for sure check that time levy's time is
taken down
h4 threatens h5 oh i don't really like
h5 for black because that pawn's on a
loose square but still black of course
is
doing very well here queen f3 hits f7 as
well yeah and take on f7
uh-oh we just take rook g7 and t1 is
hanging
wow that's crazy okay
queen of three and it's a draw of queen
g4 so he plays rookie one
oh but getting the king to g7 is huge
for levy it might not look like much but
that knight is going to sneak in f4
and the time is incredible here three oh
rook g3 was hanging with the queen on b6
king h2 i like that move for white queen
f3 hitting the pawn
yep and the wrestling e4 queen takes h5
that's a big pawn to lose
because now it's overwhelming okay takes
queen f3
oh f2 is hanging and then queen f5 oh
he must slip maybe no but he's gonna
take it now i guess it didn't matter he
is a piece that 95 too powerful
oh my goodness if i'm james i'm
resigning i want more
three you look like a mouse yeah i kind
of did right stop one move short
one square short i said queen takes b7
uh yeah hang on
this is i would play this out check it
don't check
nicely done yeah nice done queen f2 is
the threat
queen would have won here goodness check
again
queen d5 check would have traded queens
oh okay blender the queen yeah he just
laughed about it kind of he's like it's
too much to ask
wow that felt like a bullet game because
we spent so much time
at the like three seconds of peace uh
portion that was insane
that was extremely wild and
james goes for bishop takes h6 which was
completely unnecessary
but still dazzling and i don't know if
it was
truly justified but he went with it and
he
paid the price
levy looks like he's playing this game
like his hand
is playing this game but his brain is
still in the last game
he he's just like you know what the hell
just happened there
well his position is bad with white on
move seven right knight d5 was played if
the bishop goes this way knight e3 comes
to mind
or just taking e5 first and yeah this
feels
like there's too many loose squares in
white's position to be truly comfortable
let's take it by e6 that's what he's
gonna do
this is bad this is bad i like knight e3
i would take that bishop
that was my first instinct but then i
was like wait maybe i'll just feel a
calmer he says no yeah
no i i think that e6 is the better move
maybe
but i just can't refuse i just can't
remember this knight takes g3 there's no
mate
i teach you three levy throwing in that
in between move but
hang on he's just thinking about it now
and he knows that he missed that
oh yeah his face his reaction there was
like what am i doing
he wanted the brilliancy prize i'm just
gonna show
quickly what levy wanted you know
queen g6 checkmate hello but um
doesn't work like that knight takes g3
and he's down was it two pieces robert
yeah he could take on d7 but that just
gets one piece back and
trades queens and the black king is safe
so what's interesting about that moment
right there
is i didn't really like white's position
anyway but it felt like what james had
done in the previous game kind of like
an
unnecessary tactical idea and it
backfired
more immediately for levy than it did
for james but still that was
clearly an oversight don't play knight
e5 or knight
c5 here or proper i guess e5 is okay
yeah knight c5 takes on f7 and you lose
your queen
right so he plays knight h5
bringing the knight back into the game
he's up two pieces right now
yeah it's just crazy you have to take on
d7 unfortunately it's just
you must do that what about queen d5
here
queen d5 yeah that's a funny one queen
defy i like it i like queen d5
i think windy five you had to play
knight e5 and sacrifice your night that
way and you're you're winning
but and then just knight f6 after it
forced you to at least find a single
move there
just play e6 james takes king back or g6
all fine the knight's gonna come to f6
so a
full full extra what is it peace for
canty he's got the two bishops as well
there's a rook on h3
everything's wrong here for levy but you
know that that doesn't need reiterating
it's just
can james canty the third put this game
away and tie this match up again
well i think levy's doing the right
thing by playing on first of all there's
a king on f7 that could
become a problem later it's not going to
but also levy has
been the better player in time for this
is devastating queen b2 queen g1
yeah that's it yeah that's because queen
c3
like hitting the rook and hitting that
not only is there bishop b4 winning the
queen but there's bishop g7
this queen takes check on g1 that's just
nothing works here
yeah yeah he digs b2 he's gonna play on
though because he wants to get to the
bullet portion
without seeing his uh
his match score go down right he's if
you lose this game or when he loses this
game because he yeah
he will still be tied in the match and
he is the favorite in the bullet so i
think it's smart
in terms of match strategy to play on
here yeah this
is this is as over as a as a game
gets really um james is up on time
the evaluation is like
-14 i don't know this is like this is
like some sort of
cleveland brown spread or something what
are we watching here
hey the browns just won up the playoff
game so don't hate on them too much
no i was uh i was cheering for them
against the stars
yeah they uh that would that well that
wasn't even a game right the first
quarter was 28 nothing that was
ridiculous but this position is kind of
like that actually
yeah after seven moves or whatever it
was james was
up a piece so yeah this is no good is
that queen on a1
not helping queen h7 check is a threat
rook takes d7 comes to mind so
you need to be a little bit careful if
you're james and probably knight to f6
just says none of any of that for you
yeah i'm trying to find a check but h7
is covered g6 is covered
ugh yeah queen is going to go to c1 now
yeah that queen on v2 is like you know
that the
kid and capture the flag who's hiding
out in your territory for the
whole round you sort of forget about him
sure then it's
uh the right moment just pounces and
takes the yeah
he just pops off and grabs the flag and
starts running
it's the hero that you need but not the
one you deserve so there's 95 check and
there's queen h7 check we got
checks threatened oh 95 okay king f8
king e8 also there's no checks after
that yeah
e8 queen h7 there's queen e5 yeah
but it does look like levi's made
progress and he's also up on time
and we've seen james blunder in time
trouble yeah
yeah like let's talk about the fact that
the pieces that james is
up he hasn't moved yet right they are on
the queen side so
it's like it's a matter of time before
that happens and what is he setting up
here
some sort of like knight g6 or queen h7
move
she's got some hopes okay you can't play
b6 next because you're working aids
hanging so it's like
frustrating because you're of course
winning
with the black pieces here but you you
need to make moves like rook to b8 and
james
play the move quickly so that's a good
move to play and the time deficit is
about to
be nothing okay e8
safe move yeah
e6 is covered he's just gonna go back he
wants queen h7 now
that's the idea but canty is not having
any of that knight g4
bishop g7 everything looks covered wow
queen g6 check king f8 it's just amazing
bishop g7 h6
wait bishop do you have a queen g6 jack
and if queen f7 is rook d8 right
yep and there's knight h6 oh god knight
takes h6
wait this is actually a bit scary is a
queen g6 check you have the king
east all right can't f8 maybe
yeah i think queen g6 check i mean we
need to see that on the board
whoa c4 that can't be it but it it at
least cause confusion because
e6 may loosen the c6 square or b5 was
played but maybe there's a check on c6
at some point that you have to watch out
for is a queen h7
queen f7 now because rook f8 okay can't
he still hasn't really established the
rest of his pieces in this game
and i think he's about to yeah he got it
bishop d7 is huge
now the knight on g4 is covered by the
bishop on g7 canty is
i think he's fine though and bishop d4
check should be
sufficient okay where's the mate there
should be five wins there it is
oh and that's that and i mean honestly
like
i'm pretty impressed that that levy took
the game that far that was
that was really impressive but let's not
forget that that game was actually just
candy uh taking advantage of levy's
blunder of a full
piece in the opening going for a fancy
movie e6
yep and so the match is now tied
and now we have a french again and
it's not your everyday french where
black has double pawns
and white didn't have to give up the
dark square bishop to
encourage blacks to get those double
wait a second queen f3 is coming if you
play bishop v7 so be careful
yeah i guess you can survive with like
queen d7
because the knight is nowhere near but
f6 is hanging in those lines oh yeah f6
is hanging
so yeah that's true this is weird
and d7 is just not the move you want to
do
by the way even after bishop d7 queen f3
knight e7 like bishop takes d7 you have
to take with the king f6 is hanging
that's not even clear no so queen d5
played
and that protects the knight attacks the
bishop and attacks the g2 pawn so c4
will be met by queen take g2 but then
def oh my goodness this has to
that would be wild c4 queen takes g2 d5
and then queen takes h1 bishop takes c6
check
too much to calculate yeah i'll let them
do it
[Laughter]
it looks to my eyes especially if this
were a bullet game i would be playing
that
so quickly but considering it's still
blitz
for james you have so many options you
can play bishop back to e2 and then put
the bishop on f3
i like that i think that is the best
move and i wouldn't be surprised to see
that by kante after
some calculation here um we just don't
want to see these players throwing away
the game early on like c4d5 could just
be losing
and we've seen a number of games so far
just thrown away in the opening
too much time being spent though like
you just need to move
yeah he should be e2 i think he's going
to play c4 and d5 based on oh he plays
queen b3
i was like based on the amount of time
he's spending he wants to castle what
what no he doesn't what does he want to
do here
he's going to play d5 and then castle
and take on c6 and all that good stuff
yeah yeah d5 castle wow
so queen takes g2 d5 first or
orc castle looks like d5 first yeah d5
first
queen takes h1 and then maybe just
castle there or bishop c6 first all
looks good
yeah pretty wild position and i saw
levy's face he was like
first shot then he's like oh and then
now he's like okay
now that i've gone through my visceral
reactions let me actually calculate
and maybe quitting g2 looks almost
forced to me yeah queen takes b3 keep in
mind bishop takes c6
check intermezzo you cannot get away
with just like saying oh okay
this looks wild i don't want wild let's
trade the queens that's not an option
yeah and if you move the queen back and
say well why'd you
allow the queen to come to b3 and if you
play bishop d7
i'll just trade queens and you're stuck
with this really ugly pawn structure
the double f pawns that are isolated the
d-pawn so
this seems like you might have to take
on g2 and levy
appropriately spending his time figuring
out is that just losing and if not
hey that's the move i'm going to go for
and both players basically spend about a
minute or 45 seconds a piece
looking at uh queen b3 for
james canty iii and and queen takes g2
for levy and bishop d7 now this is
the thing is we we both were like oh
we'll let the players figure it out
because it is a
really complicated position but now it's
not complicated
and it's not complicated in very
favorable ways for james
because look at the pawn structure yeah
and i think levy has
just sort of realized or he's willing to
admit that
hey these tactical struggles with james
they aren't necessary like
why don't i just take a position where
the queens are off
and i can try to just outplay him uh
on the board um because those tactical
games are not always working out for him
no they are not and even this position
with the bad pawn structure
it's not that bad for black it's kind of
playable yeah yeah for sure you
uh can trade off some pieces your rooks
will
just try to go to e8 maybe won't go to
g8 it's obviously better for white
but it's not so clear-cut and now f5 all
right
king d2 i think and bring the king to d3
even just
yeah yep that definitely looks good
um even bishop f4 if you want to go for
for that trade is perfectly fine here
and important to note there's no rook g8
because knight f6 check will
fork the king and rook so
okay g3 it's one of these positions of
mine where
you know that f4 for black is an idea
but you're never sure if you actually
should play it
absolutely i was thinking the exact same
thing it's like you play it and then
usually as soon as you do you regret it
and you're like why did i just give up a
pawn for nothing
basically you're shattering white's pawn
sure but down in the palm but you're
also giving white the g
file which is not ideal so he does move
his king to c6 i like that move actually
and now what yeah he wants to play
rookie 8 but knight f6 was simply gonna
win the exchange there rookie eight
there's not a knight g7 so
that's hilarious yeah gotta watch it for
all that
oh knight g7 you called it
you called it and it's an ups oh he
didn't see it
wow that's a big miss because that was a
free pump yep
um it's weird i don't mind the move f4 i
really like the idea of fixing that pawn
as a weakness on f5 so now there is no
f4 that we've been talking about but
as you mentioned it's just only a bad
move because knight g7 was missed now if
you go knight g7 he's probably seen it
by now
but there's knight e7 to cover right and
so can you take on h7 or is f6 trapping
the knight no you move your bishop out
the way fish from anywhere bishop
oh actually f2 but then takes and bishop
e7
yeah there's also just king d7 so g oh
nice move though
rook takes e3 brook takes e3
takes bishop takes f4 and then rookie
one and you have king d2 and the f6 pawn
is hanging so your knight gets out
like what in the world yeah i think he
needed to start with the rook there
i think that was important yeah because
this exact nice move rook h8 takes nh2
with check
great king d3 and after bishop e3
okay king f3 now and then you've rookie
one rookie six
check well what you give the f4 pawn
he simply forgot that king g3 or king g5
hits the knight you don't win a knight
or anything there
yeah he was shaking his head and now
that g-pawn is
gonna try to roll up the board nine
second this is literally a time scramble
and chances for both sides the e valve
are right in the middle
just a pin drop okay knight h4 check
king g5 then i go back to f3 maybe we'll
get a draw in this way or the king
actually go up the board maybe
oh he takes the pawn levy wants more and
he can even stack the ball rook g2
okay this is good for black only move is
rook f1 now
king somewhere you get five
okay so g6 is coming this is scary yeah
oh he's gonna stack and take on c3 i
think and i like the idea
what's this 96 is his plan but c5
take it well black wins this yes yes
wait now black's definitely going to win
yep it's winning for sure
i think james really struggles in time
trouble 1994
oh my goodness but 94 was winning the c
pi might have still been winning for
black
but yeah needed to be played yeah now
this is over
to win for eleven uh yeah
i think this is a sign of things to come
if you ask me
just the scrambles pretty much
every single one that's been a 50 50 has
gone
his way yeah and that means
that we are going to be heading into the
break as you see levy
get up from his chair there he is you
know emphatic to
to take the lead at the end of the
portion which means we're going to the
bullet
one game lead for international master
levy rosman
and i mean what what do you reflect on
in that three-minute portion
if you're james canty you know
what you have to do it's just comes down
to one word move
because he's really been deliberating
and that's great he's trying to play the
best possible chess
but even in great positions he then
leaves himself with not enough time
and he doesn't feel confident in the
scramble so i think what james needs to
do
is just play these openings and he's
getting pretty decent positions out
of and just go you are not unless you
blunder in the first 10 moves you're not
going to lose
in that period of time and you need the
remaining time to be able to win
when the position gets complicated yeah
this is going to be
a very exciting conclusion and just as a
fan and a commentator
here in the booth with you robert i am
so happy that that this match has
done more than live up to expectations
because this is a very tight match
one game separates these guys and unless
someone gets completely blown out in the
bullet
portion here this is gonna be a very
exciting finish
it certainly will and the bullet remains
but for now we're gonna take a quick
break and when we return we will have
the final time patrol and the remainder
of this i'm not a gm species
championship match brought to you by
chess.com
just want to remind all of our viewers
and streamers out there that arena king
season 6
is underway it started on monday there
will be another event just two days from
now on friday
get involved have some fun and play
against some of your favorite
personalities
it will be a great time speaking of
great time we're having a blast here
as gotham chess takes on gm canty it is
a lead
for gotham levy brosnan up seven half
six and a half ahmad united were just
talking during the break
it is a lead for levy he's the high rate
the two bullet players
would you say that james has a chance or
has it gone by at this point
i think it would be um uh insulting
at this point to not say that james has
a chance he uh
was the underdog in blitz the same way
that he's going to be the underdog in
bullet
but i think he has come to play on match
day he's been playing some great chess
and whenever he's lost the game he's
bounced back with a win
so of course levy could come out of the
gate in this bullet portion
blazing and just really take it to him
and show why he's a high rated player
but what we've seen in this match so far
is james can absolutely compete
so don't count him out of this bullet
portion he's only down a single game
robert
absolutely and you and i during the
break we were looking up the history and
against teddy coleman
levy actually lost the bullet portion of
that match despite being
much higher rated so here we are what
what nice disrespect
he says get that trump asking the hell
out of here
and did you see levy laugh he's just
like what is this
there's no way that was on purpose was
it that james didn't even he didn't even
blink he was like yep knight g8 yep
now that is a power move just knight
back to g8
and looked at that one in the break what
just do you think that was a mouse slip
of sorts
what what just happened i i
but what most slope i i don't know
but nobody voluntarily goes knight back
to g8
that's wild if he wins his first game
off that that is just a power statement
i mean he's james has a terrible
position he's down
a couple tempe and his position is bad
knight f5 comes in
yeah e6 was needed there oh bishop f8 we
have the second piece returning home
robert
oh that's a sad move to play but maybe
it's not
as terrible as you think e6 okay
to h5 like oh that's yeah that's pretty
painful because black needs to play like
knight b6 bishop b7 queen e7 and castle
long
you definitely an a6 you don't have time
to play this
bishop h5 is coming yeah this is this is
gonna hurt
oh bishop h5 rook h7 holding on for dear
life needs to be
needs to be and it is queen f2 something
like that maybe rook f2 and rook f1 this
looks very painful yeah even something
slow as you said rook f2 rook
takes f7 he's got he's got nothing to
worry about an e5 he wants
yeah he's fine but trey queens yeah it's
reasonable
okay there's some chance here it's still
great for white of course when we see
the evaluation board say as much
but bishop e ah bishop b7 takes and then
bishop d6 or something
okay so bishop d7 i think you have to
play and after ef6 for bishop of a
yes wow nicely played by canty he's
pretty much
equalized the position here and he's up
on time what
in the world has happened in this game
rook v8 that b
file has come in so handy to james
throughout this match
yes absolutely bishop c6
that looks like the move there's also
h5h4 ideas if you're not careful to try
to
a5 a4 as well a5a4a3 that's actually a
really good plan here goes h5
yep uh wait takes and takes g2 you take
f6
okay take f6 is better king seven wait
that knight is kind of trapped over
there isn't it
now no knight f4 bishop check
oh well ruby two's happening so d6
though
[Music]
that is so tough can you go bishop e5
knows king f6
back h5 check dude bring that key to e7
you have to
what oh my g6 97 oh
yes oh my goodness what is happening
here
so you can't really trade rooks no he's
going to go back
to rook check brook d2 nice keep the
rooks on you have to rookie one you just
have to move you to play for
levi's time trouble here his own time
trouble
yeah that's the problem oh my goodness
he needs a move he needs to move
e4 is a good one rook g7 check e3
resolve it just resign resign
i'm telling you okay
just don't let me use things i don't
know i would play this but
it's probably a bad idea well the thing
is i'm trying to save massive
but you're right there's only one pawn
remaining so if you lose that pawn then
the game is suddenly a draw
it's not insane no rook you won rookie
one putting the rope behind the pawn was
good
yep oh he can't just keep checking you
now i would have designed it yeah knight
f2 check happening and
our king f2 king even
yeah now absolutely resigned for the
match
but i i sort of get why he's playing on
basically he sees that one point
just get that pawn off the board you
know it will be a draw
i would have resigned so long ago it's
wasting the best strategy
yeah and
yeah oh we both the same exact reaction
just a small oh
honestly though canty after playing
knight g8 which
we're going to have to ask him
oh gosh and he plays this version of the
french
the monte carlo variation and this is
interesting because you get an isolated
pawn but you get really good activity
around it
but i was gonna say hang on a bullet you
take on h3
every time so this is like how magnus
lost to bujong zee this like
famous attacking game where he just
stacked and
it's like what are you gonna do about it
wait so does this work isn't white go
like queen f3 now and just
okay queen so queen of three knight
there queen g3 doesn't work i mean
h3 queen h3 looks playable
okay he played queen g2
wow this is wild knight f3 check is a
devastating threat this queen is your
mate will follow so
you probably have to i think you gotta
grab it
take it and then you should have worked
just give up uh
give up the rook or the exchange rather
oh wow okay it covers the f3 square
wow that's it covers e2 that is a tough
move to play when you don't have much
time
so if c6 okay if we move that to f5 so
never mind very reasonable position yeah
i like that as well just get the bishop
out of the way wow this is a wild game
and james down a lot of clock yeah james
is
laser focused right now and his life is
just sipping water
he's more used to playing these bullet
scrambles so that's going to come in
handy it has been
the better player between the two in the
bullet
so far and okay bishop f3 he's trying to
get rid of the attackers but just take
on e3 a bunch of times
f4 hangs there's also bishop c5
um to pin the uh
the e3 okay this doesn't look as bad as
it once did
yeah the knights going back like that i
mean it's all about time at this point i
think james has done a fantastic job
defending him yeah
he really has he's all these pieces
towards his king although f5 is a great
move
bishop c2 in knight g4 the knight comes
in g3 i guess you have to
yeah okay nitrogen
so knight e3 pawn takes knight g4 and
then e knight moves out the way this is
such a wild position
my goodness it's too cluttered so he
fixes something i agree with this
decision even just like g6 or like
knight g4 bishop c5
those type of moves yeah and i think
that
no matter what james is going to bring
his knight to either d or f4
three seconds a piece yep f5 is going to
be hanging sometimes bishop 396 kind of
stuff
yep he plays e4 that's oh that is a
risky move
can't really get behind that three
minimum 93 all right that makes sense
we're 64. now this is opening up for
both sides
and actually oh no we needed rookie for
it yeah rookie four looked better
to trade off some pieces no eve one's
hanging oh it's hanging
yeah this is the scheme but but it is
clear if he had played brooke takes e4
there
robert that absolutely could have led to
even the checkmate for white
yeah i mean i'm still trying to wrap my
head around all those tactics and
that's what happens to us chess players
right we see this and we're like
wait what just happened let me let me
remember was there does that work
and the next game is fully underway so
queen takes b2 here by kante
you're down three points on the
scoreboard you just have to take the
pawn and
hope that you tell the tale yeah and
let's be clear
in bullet all the games that we've seen
so far
are gonna work out just that little bit
better for
levy just because of the fact that the
time is lower and
it's even going to castle i think he's
going king f1 and knight t5 ideas
yeah because you try to open up the h
file so that rook
is dominating an attack i think this is
a crut i think
this might be a crush for levy bishop c3
g3 knight g5
yeah i did like to move bishop f4
because at least it creates some threats
and
caused some confusion but you're right
bishop c3 just to get out of it don't
trade pieces
the queen has to go but where does it go
too ooh queen e7 rookie 2 to e2 with
tempo
yeah rook b1 players
okay this suddenly isn't as bad as i
thought it was going to be this should
be five you have to
and black has an extra pawn but white
has the bishop pair
and what could be a nasty attack yeah i
still think king king g2
rookie one f4 is it's gonna be like
really rough here yeah but yeah
you gotta you gotta take this a scan to
take that bond and play this game out
that's how you gotta try it
so he plays knight f6 but he just gives
up the pawn in the center and now he
doesn't even extra material for his
troubles
right so he's gonna have to rely on some
kind of b5 at some
point maybe take a bishop g4 or just
bishop g4
initially i think taking is maybe a bit
better but
the level is the same yeah levy just in
time your king g2 because that bishop
could sit on f3
that'd be a problem for white's
coordination but he got his
communications almost trapped by the way
yeah it's a close call takes takes f3
there is
e3 as a resource and not only does it
save the day it actually just turns
black's position into a promising one so
a good move knight d7 levy sitting and
thinking
he is down right back to e1 tough move
to play but i like it yeah
tough move to play i agree he does it
wow great move
yeah that's that's a classy move there
f3 intended next with g4 h5
he's gonna whip that out i think
although the problem is that c4 pawn on
light square the knight and bishop can
team up so if somehow this bishop gets
some open space
from d7 it can apply pressure knight a4
happens a6 b5 likely a follow-up and you
called it
that's gonna be on the board and these
two bishops i mean they're gonna be
dangerous in the end game but they're
more dangerous with the queen on the
board and how about three seconds
for levy yeah he's had no time so many
different games in this match and here
just take on e4 play rook on d8
rook d8 it looks good yep
you think he's deep if you don't play
rook d and d7 rookie eight is kill it
with bishop g7 check so f6 here and if
before g5 you kick the bishop away you
win the d6 pawn
this is huge look at that time as well
yeah and then 94 seconds
and the 984 is a hero protecting that c5
pawn
oh but here comes here comes levy and
slowing down is james canty we've seen
this before
we have and he put the knight in the
wrong square knight b2 without the
knights go to d3 with check
to fork the bishop if it captured on c5
so still is this okay for canty base at
least got to draw here
although he might win this yeah he's got
to put pawns on light squad 35
oh he didn't do it and i was waiting his
nice trap he's gonna lose
oh my gosh he's gonna lose wow he's lost
this game
oh that is devastating that might be
everything right there and he knows he's
shaking his head
wow yeah that's that
wow wow
that's one of those games where you
can't
fathom how you lost you were up a pawn
in an end game where there were like six
pieces on the board and yet his knight
got trapped
and the g3 pawn would have been
protected so a win
for levy rosman and he's just running
away with this match
he's gotta basically james has to start
winning right now
he he has to start winning um
because the time he's gonna decide this
match that the match time
13 minutes and ticking down yeah and i i
mean i like what he's doing here you
need to win you need to win quickly
let me sacrifice one pawn sacrifice a
second break open the position and if
you take on f5 bishop g2 the d
whoa okay i guess the uh d4 pawn was
pinned there so
it works out wow and getting e4 is huge
if white could somehow break with c4
that would [ __ ] shatter the entire pawn
structure and shake up things entirely
but
look at these pawns h5 t4 d5 e4 so
frustrating
yeah the bishop's just locked in there
on g2 and you somehow can't
uh get the base pawn the d5 pawn
can't be taken okay nicely done so some
kind of knight c5 makes sense to me but
lavi should ignore it
it's like knight g5 just to try to open
up the d file and get to the d5 pawn but
exactly closing the position down i
think the knight is trying to go to e3
but a bishop on f4 will make that's so
hard to do and yeah he's trying to get
c4 but b4 says
it's amazing how levy's piece is just
completely
dominating here bishop f4 to g5 knight
f6
bishop so don't fall for that bishop e4
right so okay he stopped it and this
remember yeah king d6 also worked
no just take on e3 take that was good
enough king d6 is a great move as well
uh levy is kind of in cruise control at
the moment
he's stopping to hydrate a little bit
yeah now uh the match is completely out
of control for
james canty and well i think if you're
levy you look at the score it's about to
be
five point lead only 11 minutes left and
you're the one dominating the bullet
portion
you must be thrilled considering how
this match looks just
five games ago exactly it's a great
great point i mean
white's kind of pretending to hold on
here but the position is actually
so so lost um like rook c8
i think he's probably good enough yeah i
can't protect your c2 pawn rook g3
can happen any moment as well but
this is solid rook g3 rook g3 bishop d2
bishop c3 check
white can't move completely frozen
bishop e3
i'm just he's finding everything now
every move just that
takes the life out of james's pieces
like knight g4 is simple enough yeah i'm
just gonna go for that
indeed in the nice trap still oh
h3 is even playable bishop d2 to c3 and
h3 i think h3 rook g1 just wins the
night
that's you're right oh wait that was a
little blunder there
it looks a little blunder yeah he's got
three seconds but you gotta move
he's gotta move that's for sure wow he
keeps doing that
and rookie three did james somehow
survive this king c1
that was a big blunder a series of
blenders wow
c3 get a pass spot yep c4 same idea
and this should be a draw with best play
but when you're playing bullet there is
no best play it's just no
not at all king is coming to f5 and e4
this is scary
wow whose pawn is going to be better you
give up the d-pawn but you push up on
the b6
king c5 i like when you did that f3 rook
before check so you
have to watch out for that and here b6
take a take on d5 even d6
yeah you can take on default works wait
but who's if you can't allow that queen
if you allow that queen you're going to
check oh now he's got a rook f5 he's
covering him he's going to at least get
a draw here
and king c7 and that's a draw wow wow
so a huge covenant that game was over
robert
that's what happens as commentators when
you call a game before it actually
concludes
the other results happen and yeah here
we have another wild position
with knight to d5 he's giving up a
knight because the bishop on the d5 is
saying
it's just crazy takes knight back to c6
f4 this looks like a position that
probably both players wanted
from the opening honestly bishop d3
kind of looks like black should be
pretty happy right now
unless you can get your knight to d4 and
bishop to e3 but i always have queen b6
and your bishop is stuck
oh that looks like a good move takes
back and then play b4 again
now oh now he gets it with bishop e3
though this could be concerning
although f6 right standard french type
of have to play f6 and he does he does
yeah
and then center's collapsing and the
white kings in the center take on e5
steal a pawn don't mind if you do right
absolutely bishop d7
i mean there were pawns for the taking
there
and some kind of queen h4 comes to mind
knight takes e5
still it was finally yeah you guys shook
my e3
he could take it anyway and long last
it's gone
okay so he's just playing rookie one
maybe king h1
bishop f4 or something like that from
levy
although trading off pieces has knight
takes e6 and bishop takes e6
maybe an option i don't know no but it's
bishop e6 and bishop takes h3
so you just keep the exchanges happening
there
yeah yeah there might have been like a
bishop c5 at the end of that one but
just
wild stuff yeah too much to calculate
it's bullet it's bullet guys yeah just
take
with the pawn everything take dc7
right and e5 falls but then it's queen
b8
if you take eight and maybe you should
make the the diamond structure play b5
yeah
b5 for sure oh uh on
that's hanging oh that is bad
protected past a pawn here
that might be it that might be the game
right there if that pawn can get to a5
okay so that's actually c8 doesn't work
uh he takes a three queen c3
rookie six because you just have to
trade off things but
yep this is just good for life levi in
these critical moments he just finds
a way to like slip away from pressure
and then
find the counter shots when they're
available to him clutch
yeah yeah has been and let's see here
you take on c6 rook takes and the rook's
going to try to go to g6
so it puts his rook on d1 which makes
sense
looks like a good move james is just
down to the final seconds
the problem is he can't trade i like
queen a7 but there's just nothing you
can offer after we're d5 here
well you traded and take on a4 and you
rook d5 or b8 rookie one check
that was nasty nice fine there and queen
takes
and yeah canteen doesn't have any hope
here because
the back rank's covered and levy can
just close his eyes and push those pawns
yeah now it's easy one second
taking down like at this point is just
too clinical for levy rosman as
he is going to push those two pawns up
the board and they cannot be stopped
nope and now it is a five game lead
with just under six minutes remaining
the match
is levies and well we have
some fun opening with the bishops
opening and then early d4
just to cause some confusion yeah we
needed maybe
more of this in general from him in this
match but it looks
like this is going to be levi's match
there's there's pretty much no
mathematical way
that canton comes back because there's
just not enough time
on the clock to get those games in right
and we
sort of have like an evan's gambit
with an e5 though yeah this this has to
be bad queen d5 was coming so that's why
he played d5 and queen
a4 i don't know how this works but queen
a4 check at some point it's gonna be
painful like queen a4
but you can just go takes on f6 take
some support
queen trade take on g7 bishop g5 i'm
sure that's also like
pretty reasonable looks good
he plays bishop b3 the calm move which
after 94. he's going to castle just like
give up all his bones
yeah we know the vibe here
yeah we know what's happening and look
at this bishop a3 you're typical don't
castle
can't get away with that take all my
pawns your king stuck in the center
me too i'm here for this yep
19 seconds ticking down here yeah now
like knight d4 f4
f5 type of stuff what we saw at the end
of the alexandra and greg match
in this event was alexander got this
amazing checkmate in the final bullet
game
it's almost like once you know you've
won the match you
kind of let your guard down a little bit
like if you're levy here
um maybe he wouldn't have taken this
position if the match was on the line
right you can just play whatever you
want because the match is yours you're
moving on to the next round
totally true and queen d3 played i think
levy can please his development knight
d7
and yeah absolutely c4
i mean e5 hanging knight g4 coming
bishop back to c7
yep
and yeah there's going to be knight f3
check
like puzzle rush style yeah queen h2 at
the knife through now
takes queens i'm sure it works queen h3
oh this move order hurts too because
there's knight of three check oh knight
f3
queen uh levy oh my goodness he doesn't
see it
it would have been beautiful yeah he's
still cruising
he's still winning yeah but that was a
nice puzzle rush finish knight f3 check
uncovering mate on h2 isn't that
frustrating in puzzle rush when you find
a winning tactic
but it's not the most winning right
because there was checkmate there
levy's obviously crushing right now but
he wouldn't have solved it correctly as
he didn't get the check yeah if this was
exactly in a puzzle rush competition
that
wouldn't be good enough so what's he up
now uh
rook and sorry in exchange in three
pawns
three pawns yep bishop v5 probably the
most crucial move
in the position looking to trade
okay getting tricky but not tricky
enough just takes takes h6
hoping for not so fast
yeah so it's two and a half minutes left
i think we'll get
one more game after this one concludes
and levy just liquidating as he is up
three pawns and then game b3 a4 a3 it's
yeah this will be it and as you
mentioned two minutes left
probably one more game for these players
yeah and it's interesting because james
is clearly flustered you saw him just
kind of be like
nothing's going right for me in the
bullet and the score
has just ballooned thanks to this
quickest time control but if you're
james
if you're going to lose the match i
think this is absolutely the way you
want to lose the match you don't want to
you know essentially be crushed in the
longer time patrols and then make up
some points
in the bullet so he should be proud of
himself he should keep his head hanging
high because
he played a great match and i think what
he'll regret honestly is some of these
earlier games
in the time scrambles he just wasn't
able to work out that especially the
game
where levy found that stalemate and it
was a draw of rather than a win for
james
yep oh that's a great point and he
definitely should be feeling good about
this game
levy also i mean who knows what his game
plan coming in was but
i'm sure he knew at the back of his mind
that hey
i am a fantastic bullet player and i can
win this match
in that time control as long as i stay
steady in the blitz like
uh he might not be happy with how the
blitz went for him but at the same time
yeah i'm sure it was a little bit part
of his game plan to to
crush the bullet portion yeah we saw
really two different
gotham chesses we saw the early gotham
chess
who was struggling against james's
tactics and james really played very
well there
and then we got like sort of positional
crushing gotham where
in those two games in the three minute
portion with the white pieces he just
was kind of in cruise control he just
dominated the board and james had no
chance
and then of course he showed his full
might here in the bullet
and has taken over this match yep
exactly um here it looks like there's
just going to be a
night move into a three piece
i'm trying to see how to get out of that
yeah that's wait so take an e6 some
bishop d5 kind of stuff
but oh knight g3 you also hit the rook
on f1 the queen that's why knight f5 was
such a good move
yeah and i'm wondering if levy's just
looking at the match clock seeing their
10 seconds left
he could just resign at some point after
the 10 seconds yeah he wants to make
sure that time goes to zero
no no sense playing another game
honestly for either of these players as
the match
is over okay for sure
and well what is black up right now
looks like a lot it's
in exchange knight f6 looks like the end
of the game
followed by five c4 is resourceful
yeah it feels like lovey's found so many
ideas like that where
it looks like the game should just be
over and he plays like c4 just to give
himself
chances and that's completely necessary
if you're going to win a match
like this okay trae queens
this limit living on the edge there
probably you have to take the queen and
go a4 is white
yeah and then what's black up exactly
like an exchange in two pawns
yeah and hey i called it i
i mean if he ends up winning this game i
was just saying
that's somehow how these matches tend to
end
is the the guy who's gonna end up losing
the match
oh that's funny funny that he's still
winning
right like 96 checking queen oh you're
in the room
that's awesome that's uh that's fun
promoting to a bishop
that's a classy way to end that's the
the comedy we expect from from levy
there for sure and for candy ending on a
win that at least
feels better than what it previously
happened we are going to grab the
players
they'll join us for post-match
interviews i'm on we're going to think
of some good questions because
that match had us on the edge of our
seats you you said it best
robert um you know full credit to both
levy rosman for obviously the victory
and moving on to the next round but also
to james candy for a
incredibly uh good performance and it
made this match a lot closer than i
think people
expected it to be and i was thoroughly
entertained so i can't wait to talk to
these guys in the post game interview
for sure everybody stay tuned we'll be
right back with both levy rosman and
james kane iii
with their thoughts on what was a
fantastic match we'll be right back
and we return with both of our great
players
you of course know their faces but let's
hear their thoughts
let's start with you levy congrats on
winning was a really fun match
where did you feel like you found your
best form because out of the gates it
seemed a little bit shaky for you
and then suddenly you went on a tear
down the stretch
uh bullet kind of saved me uh it was a
very back and forth match
i mean i it's it's no i didn't expect
anything less honestly i was doing some
prep this morning
and i was like all right candy and i
will fight it out in the blitz and
hopefully i'm within you know i'm up one
or two or
and i i didn't even think about the
bullet i also thought the bullet would
be close but then as it got going i was
like okay
i seem to be making the better decisions
like within one or two seconds so
um stressful as hell though man that was
not fun
yeah that was a stressful match for us
watching i mean the the blitz portion
was just
topsy-turvy it seemed like the time
scrambles at the end
levy you had that one stalemate that
robert and i
remember there's like a king on a1 and
kante's king was running around
and that was just the wildest game for
the emotions of the chat and us
any any thoughts there uh
yeah i was um i i was very happy from
the opening and then
as the game was going on i was like what
the hell am i doing i was like
like jamming to my music i was like i'm
gonna be up two and then he just started
kicking my ass and i was like what is
going on
and then i was gonna resign i was just
gonna resign and i'm like you know what
f and h could be a draw
like or whatever a and z could be a draw
and then i was like how do you draw this
with like two seconds on my clock
and that was the end yeah yeah and james
on your end i mean that must have been
really deflating yeah we saw your
reaction i mean
what was that experience like how do you
calm yourself because there was so much
match
left to play well man that was tough i
was like bro what am i doing you right
i'm like but i felt confident and good
because i knew i was like yo only only
chant
not chance but the only time that's
going to be very hard for me is going to
be in bullet i knew that
ahead of time of course he's 2800 i
don't play like i'm working on really
you know i'm really trying to make gm so
i don't play as much bullet as i used to
but at the same time um like i had to be
prepped and
i was like man levy's a monster and
bullets so i knew it was going to be uh
a problem there but
what how do you bounce back is hikaru
said uh i remember he
had an article a long time ago or maybe
he said it but he said um you gotta have
short term memory loss when it comes to
losses or games like that like just
you cannot think about that going into
the next game or is going to affect
everything so
yeah that's where i was i was like yep
just shake it off keep moving
next game oh i certainly didn't do that
there was that game where i was winning
in the end game the game they went like
40 moves longer than it had to
uh because i i didn't know how much time
i had like for the first time in my life
i'm looking at the board i don't know
how much time i have because i think i
have like one second so i just keep
moving i hang a knight
and then you don't take it and then i'm
just like i just gotta move and then
finally i look i have three seconds
it's crazy like playing on stream you're
just like talking to chat
like drinking thank you for the prime
you got two seconds on the clock and
then like here it's just like
like it's insane man
well you know you're mentioning upstream
and of course you both are very popular
you had
many fans throughout the match rooting
you both on
so let me ask you let's start with you
levy what's the difference for you
because you do play in title tuesdays
and things like that but what's the
difference between that
and the match you just played in just
this tournament more generally
uh i think i have the same experience
today that i did uh
the last time that i that i played this
thing i i honestly like
my nerves are like sky high i might have
to take a shot of something before i
play next time it's crazy i haven't
played a meaningful chess game in like
two years
three years how long has it been so i
like get amped up for this but when i'm
sitting here i'm like
you know you just go you just go i mean
you see it like with the time spent five
plus one
i think in five plus one my level of
play goes down thirty three percent
at least it's a weird format i i believe
that actually and bullet it was much
stronger i was like where was where did
this come and he was also fast and
accurate
he was getting time trouble but i was
like man he's going to be a monster and
bullet and that's exactly what happened
i was like man i just want to get a few
games bro like make it close
because i knew this is going to be tough
for me i'm not even playing as much
bullet demand 2800
okay that's nasty and bullets so i was
like yeah i know i gotta
this is gonna be tough that one second
increment definitely saved me but it
still wasn't enough time it still wasn't
the time bro but it was uh you know
congrats bro it was great
and i felt great about the match but
could have did better bullet
yeah the the bullet portion was
entertaining i know
robert and i both saw the pretty much at
the beginning of the bullet portion
i think levy was like on camera looking
shocked when you played
knight f6 knight back to
and we're all wondering was that was
that a mouse slip like what was that
there
that was not a mouse slip big fella that
was definitely something that i play
a lot actually because it just throws
people off especially in bullet knight
g8 and we great hit h6 g5 bishop g7 d6
975
c5 go for a queen side attack it's more
like a uh black lions a shout out to
simon williams on that i know
a l shot system if you guys are familiar
with that but sort of a combination of
both where you get this
swashbuckling ridiculous looking game
especially in bullet chess is something
nice
yeah james really caught us off guard
with that one glad to know that was
planned
and that was fun and you know people in
the chat were mentioning before and i
guess i have to ask
both of you i guess there's breaking
news that james harden was trades the
nets
levy you're a brooklyn guy how are you
feeling about that
uh shocked and uh wow i'm kind of pissed
off actually i don't want james harden
i i didn't want james harden i don't
know
oh my god wow you got to lose that
weight that's why that's what i can say
you gotta lose that weight i mean so do
i but so does he
robert how do you feel about that better
question oh you know i'm the one who
asked the questions i don't have to
answer them right now yeah you're not
happy
i need a rep and you wrap my head around
all of it the last thing that we needed
in brooklyn was the
the top three most dramatic players in
the league let's be serious okay
well guys it was an awesome match and
really thank you so much to both you
and congrats to you levy for finally
taking it and for james you put up a
great fight you were worthy competitor
and we look forward to more
streams of yours in the near future
appreciate it guys
thanks guys yeah congrats levy and as
you see the bracket fills out a little
bit more our third match has come
to its conclusion levy rosman the four
seed moves on he awaits the winner of
eric rosen
and sagar shah what do you make of that
match up
in the 512 because if you're a college
basketball fan that's
normally where opposites happen yeah you
know fifth seed versus twelve seed i
think that
um one of the sort of dark horses or the
one of the people that
uh i think the audience might know the
least about in this tournament might be
cigar shaw i mean
uh you and i probably uh quite familiar
with him but
i i think that people would be more
familiar with eric rosen you know like
very popular
on his streams and such and he's
obviously the favorite going in but
i think if this match was any indicator
robert it's like
what does a favorite really mean in this
format it's about who shows up
on game day because james canty came in
he was only down a single game
and he was leading at many points in
this match it's only done a single game
before the bullet so
i think it's gonna be a very exciting
match just like today rosen is the
favorite but anything can happen
yeah another matchup of fabulous content
creators cigarshaw
also a very strong player and many
people especially on twitch may not be
as familiar but if you're on youtube
you should look up his stuff great
content and he may be
the most popular uh person in this match
because when he is streaming when the
indian players are playing
oh the audience grows and grows so it
will be interesting to see how
he fares over the board and not in his
role's commentator but
i'm on you know it's been fun we will
have
another match tomorrow between alessia
santoramo and roberto molina
i think we know who the heavy favorite
is in that one roberto is the two seed
unless he will have her hands full but
any chance
for the 15 seed i i think i've i've
learned my lesson you know
in these matches where for example levy
the fourth seed
james canty the third number 13 and how
close was this match to start off there
were many points where kante was leading
i've i've learned to you know
not put my money anywhere anywhere near
matches like this because the
incredible things can happen so i'm not
counting anyone out
and even in some of the matches like
danny versus lawrence
which ended up in a lopsided score it
was still a very entertaining match so
it's well worth your time
to tune in certainly and well you know
many more fun chess events coming our
way there's the arena kings
as starting starting monday
and the second arena kings will be
friday of course we will have
pog champs three everyone should be
really excited about that that is
starting next month the biggest names in
the streaming world
v tubers like code miko and of course
the
uh celebrities abound including some
from
non-streaming platforms like rayne
wilson of the office and daniel negrano
the poker legend
amman you know it's been a great time
covering these matches with you i had a
blast today
and wow we just were in for a show that
was a treat
yeah and the time just like disappeared
it always happens during these matches
you never you never see the time taken
away and at the end that was like a full
full cinematic experience i was i was
here for it all commentary with you we
had to chat
uh tons of fans and supporters for both
sides we appreciate
you know the memes the the spam you guys
enjoying it
and uh yeah just a lot of fun
commentating and uh
thoroughly entertained for sure and
there is another match tomorrow it
starts
three hours earlier so if you're tuning
into this set your clocks because you
will not want to miss that
i'm on thank you again thanks to our
producers thanks to everybody who's
joined us
throughout all the chats and throughout
all the action we really appreciate you
but for now
we're gonna sign off enjoy the rest of
your day and keep having fun with chess
take care
you